hit it [ __ ] uncle joey here
coming at you direct wednesday the 19th
of april for starters i want to thank
honor.com our main sponsors i love them
to death
supplements the best you understand me
from the acai protein to the hemp
protein to the alpha brain
go to honor.com and press in church boom
get ten percent off number two me undies
when i go to jiu jitsu when i got a suit
on when i got short time what do you
think i'm banging underneath
[ __ ] me undies you understand me you
know why cause modal micro mold ball a
fabric three times softer than cotton
but listen
go again to meundies.com look at the
selection you see something you like
preston joey and me undies will take
good care of you all right again go to
meundies.com
joey for 20 off your first pair number
three lee talk to me about blue apron oh
my god blue apron's the best i have my
dad here he loves blue i got him on blue
apron i have the whole family on blue
apron they sent everything right to your
house couldn't be easier easy delicious
recipes it's the it's the greatest all
right you heard it from my man lee you
know he's an entrepreneur he gave up
blizzard me so do me a favor
go to blueapron.com
joey
again go to blueapron.com
joey and you're gonna get your first
three meals for free all right blue
apron my undies and honey you know i
love you
kick that mule
lee you [ __ ] have no idea
what's cracking tonight
here you go
kick it lean kick it
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
von scott
rest in peace you bad [ __ ] my
australians it's the church of what's
happening now [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] kidding me
mickey gall
what's up baby lisa
hello uncle joey here we go
they got stung man weak what
and a heathen brave oh [ __ ]
right here plain and simple here we go
on a wednesday night
so go down here you go go down lick that
muffler go down lick that helmet go down
here you go go down
here you go
listen yesterday i was at home
i was cleaning my office i was throwing
[ __ ] out i had a bunch of [ __ ] in the
shells
and i put on this album ufos strangers
in the knights their live album [ __ ]
brilliant michael shankly just shredding
the [ __ ] guitar
but youtube kept popping up albums
and they popped up like cheap trick live
at buda con i almost shot myself
listening to that nonsense so i went and
clicked the next town it was let that be
rocked by ac dc
this is now that [ __ ] i listened to a
thousand times growing up and i just
forgot about it
mickey going
during the third song i had to get him
sit in my chair and start crying
like i saw myself walking up those new
jersey hills
it brings back music brings back those
emotions you felt you know oh i remember
taking a bus from union city new jersey
to seaside heights like a puerto rican
on a hit acid
with a ghetto blaster
listening to highway to hell with this
dude [ __ ] randy merkel rest in peace
and d'agostina i don't know what
happened to him he's lost somewhere in
florida
and we kept the bus driver kept pulling
over going you please gotta lower that
[ __ ] thing
once he'd get back on the road we'd
[ __ ] blast that music on it you
weren't an asset for that we went on
yeah oh my god and in those days we go
to seaside heights they used to have the
uh water slide
i don't know if they still have it down
there this is 1988. i don't think it's
water size anymore there was a water
sliding mickey going that they greased
with vaseline and the extra 10 they'd
give you a wetsuit and you would do 90
miles an hour down that [ __ ]
yeah so on saturdays this was the deal
all of us would get together we'd smoke
a few numbers
we get like a roast beef sandwich
whatever's good on the p whatever that
that at the end of seaside there's like
a sandwich place that we would drive an
hour and a half away to get the open
whatever sandwich they had just just
phenomenal
we would meet saturday and take like a
hit of acid and we'd break up into
groups
me and you mickey go we're going to see
side
siesta what's the other one next to
lbi long beach island that's further
down there's seaside and then seaside
park
tom's river yeah yeah yeah and then but
lbi is the next one where it's uppity
yeah
you had a girl from school that was
going to lbi so me and you would go to
her party yeah billy the [ __ ] kid and
dickie sayak would go to a party in
seaside park lisayet would go to a
jewish function in toms river
and the plan was that we'd all meet at
the waterslide
at 11 o'clock when the acid was burning
and we'd go on that [ __ ] water slide
and one night i almost died because i
picked up and it was a bridge
that thing would have [ __ ] taken my
head off i would have i would have
fainted you lifted huh why because i
wanted to see where my friends were and
the guys are yelling go back go back
lucky i didn't turn around
and i actually dropped like a [ __ ]
mummy
i'd have a big [ __ ] thing on my
forehead now mickey gall in the [ __ ]
what's up dog future ufc [ __ ] champ
yes sir i could see it in the [ __ ]
stars don't take a [ __ ] [ __ ] to know
you're a [ __ ] savage and [ __ ] thank
you thank you take science in the house
he thought he already took the acid
that's how many bottles he did
he asked me if we already took the ass
don't have the same weed that they have
in uh in florida it's a little bit
better no this is this is this is the
difference and you know what it's not
even about the reefer it's just
listen i could give you a five dollar
hamburger i give you a 15 hamburger
what's the difference
ten bucks the presentation yeah this
bong is a meal
this bong is like the subaru of bonks
like nobody would look at this you'd go
buy a four-footer with activation and
pumps and [ __ ] it don't do the damage
that this [ __ ] meal does
this mule doubles is a weapon you can
put a stick of dynamite in it and blow
it out at somebody you could take a
[ __ ] bottle rocket and shoot it this
is the bong of deck right here i don't
care who me i'm not giving them a plug
i'm talking about if you're looking for
a bung don't go longer than 12 inches
12 inches is the ideal [ __ ] bomb
glass you could put ice in there
what do you think mickey going hey man i
don't even think there is is that our
brand for that one it just seemed like
one of like the no the meal i'm just
gonna say it's a no-name one we just got
it from like a smoke shop a [ __ ] meal
and and the thing wherever you go
you like you have armenian people who
know you like we went to like let that
liquor that
shop and every shop in like the north
hollywood radius has at least one
armenian who you know on a first name
basis [ __ ] love him i got him i hold
the armenians close to me she goes deep
what do you think's gonna hang out with
me the gentile from the farmer's market
or the [ __ ] armenians with leather
jackets thinking they're walking around
in brooklyn the [ __ ] armors they
don't [ __ ] around
it's funny i showed dick cyan
we our studios across the street from
like a high-rise building that they
built 22 years too early in north
hollywood and now they're building north
hollywood around it
but there's a there's a lady over there
that from time to time has a red light
on
and a green light and when i was a kid
when i was like 17
we would do blow at night and drive
around and a friend of ours would always
go stop her light is on i got to go
and there was a girl named debbie and
supposedly for 40 bucks she'd [ __ ] you
around the world right there in jersey
right in our neighborhood
if our light was red that means she was
busy if the light was green come on in
[ __ ] christmas time you'd be confused
you wouldn't know what the [ __ ] to do is
he got relatives up there
they sing in the holidays but
years later like two years later i moved
out of north bergen i was living in
colorado my friends would call me arena
and they go turn on
eyewitness news you know like this is
way before cable like they had like a
something different they had
they had like a satellite or some [ __ ]
and the funny thing was that this chick
the mayor
uh they had beat a political genius in
my hometown so they were trying to get
back at this mayor
so what they did was they hired this
hooker the chick who
had the apartment on 81st street
and they made it go to channel 7
eyewitness news and say that
first off she they gave her a name debri
anne ballinger
like it was a [ __ ] joke
and this chick went on [ __ ] this news
on in new york city the biggest news
thing
and said how the mayor was her [ __ ]
pimp
and the mayor's wife these people had
heart attacks
these guys were christians
you know what i'm saying and this chicks
out there going on you don't know how
many times i've been with payoffs with
them they drop it off at a barber shop
she had all the information down where
all this [ __ ] went down
but she had never been to these places
this is way before the camera you
couldn't even prove it she said she
would blow the mayor and then sit
outside while he went to make pickups
and [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] genius only in jersey
would they pull a [ __ ] move
and they bought it in jersey they're
like yeah that could happen in jersey
that this it did it did and you know
what a year later they found that with
everyone in the veins dead
in the apartment in cliffside park
that's how you knew
that [ __ ] knew where the [ __ ] goods
were they were already indicted too
and they killed them i uh i do jujitsu
with a friend of yours a guy who grew up
with what's his name you know him as mad
dog
his name's juan
grew up with them you uh
you took some kid dirk's walkman he had
like a story with uh with you involved
you took some kid dirk's walk man
and uh he was like friends with dirk you
remember juan he's like he's like if you
said mad dog joey remember me
from where
bergen like north bergen
he told me confidently you'd remember no
no mad dog
a bell i don't remember dirk either out
of his number out of your dunbar's
number out of your brain what's that
dunbar's number
you can only remember 150 people
and then once you remember get 151
someone gets the boot i don't remember i
had i was friends with a kid dirk
in boulder colorado not the one yeah i
was friends there was a kid dirk that
was a real dick he was my boss at the
detail shop another guy that thought he
was [ __ ] cute yeah and he would come
in and give orders for no reason he was
getting like eight dollars an hour he
come in there giving all this and [ __ ]
so one day i found a dead rat
like a six-inch rat
and he was a smoker
and i took the [ __ ] rat and i put him
in his jacket pocket
and it was hanging on the tank out of
the door this idiot i forget all about
it you know me i smoked three joints i
forgot i even did it the next day he
comes to work his car is banging the
[ __ ] up
he said he wreaths in his pocket oh he
crashed
that's awesome and he pulled the rat out
he was pissed we did it good on me i
just had that grit on my face on
i hate those people they try and boss
you it's like don't boss me man like you
know what i mean i just got a person
because it's really crazy that you said
that i just got hit up
but you know facebook you get messages
but then they go somewhere
and they call something else and every
once in a while it pops up and goes you
have 36 [ __ ] messages
and i click onto it and i see 36
messages that i've never [ __ ] gotten
in my life but i don't know
about a week ago i got a [ __ ] message
from a kid i don't know you remember me
you robbed me in 1985.
he goes i just put two and two together
and he goes his name i don't want to say
his name on the [ __ ] podcast
he said what his name was and it was
dirk it was about a walkman no i'm just
getting another one
no i don't think unless it was a new
walkman that we got in the box or
something
i don't remember i don't know i don't
know the whole story i wish he but
anyway he does jiu jitsu now he's a he's
like a fuchsia white belt he's got his
kid in it nice guy
yeah it's weird i don't remember that
but this guy
i remembered
he's you know what in those days like if
you [ __ ] with me
like weird like if you told me you had
good weed and i showed up and i told my
friends and it was [ __ ] weed we just
robbed you like a year later yeah just
for being a [ __ ] jerk off we just
rock yeah this guy did something stupid
to me sure and i went to his house it
was the funniest thing he had a social
security check like a tax return in the
mail
and i [ __ ] took it because i had a
banker who would cash those checks in
those days he told me bring me anything
for ten percent i'll cash anything
so i took his check
and i took a brand new car stereo in a
box he had in his apartment like an
eight ball
and i left how i left i left like a week
later for colorado
and about a year later a friend of mine
goes man i bumped into
he said you robbed his house for a car
stereo an eight ball
his social security check [ __ ] yeah i
did
and he even said himself because you did
so well i forgive you
because you turned to do something with
your life i forgave you i just want you
to know i'm cheering for you and [ __ ]
thank you for robbing me
he goes honor
he goes it's one of my favorite stories
i tell it now at the holidays it's a
badge of honor again
you could do like one of those tours you
know how in hollywood they have those
like vans they cut the tops off of i
rolled this house and i robbed that
house
that dropped joey diaz victims
there's a guy on facebook i gotta tell
you something
it's been
35 years
and he still won't let it go
like he's still
well
well how much do you get him for a half
ounce of coke what is that worth at that
time
maybe a thousand bucks i'd still be mad
but he would bump he would bump into my
friends and cry like you don't
understand i had to get a part-time job
at a tire store
because that guy just please if you bump
into him
tell him just to give me half it'll be
forgotten
but the funny thing was this guy [ __ ]
with me for a while
you know those people that like when
they have you by the balls they enforce
it like i was bringing him tvs okay yeah
you're working for okay i had a guy that
was giving me tvs and boxes i was giving
this guy a great deal and he's busting
your balls i would give him that and go
all right give me a grandma blow and we
would be even
one night doing an ozzy osbourne concert
i went over and i go here's the tv and
he goes i'm giving you a half gram
tonight
i go okay so you made it right yourself
i never said nothing to him i didn't say
i didn't get mad i told my friends and
they're like that [ __ ] we'll see
him again
you know it wasn't like an important
thing and sure enough
it's eight months later because the
concert was in october like in june
it was like the hottest night of the
[ __ ] june in jersey when it gets
humid
and me and my buddy are popping [ __ ]
uh
vodka grapefruit with orange juice what
do you call those sea breezes we thought
we were johnny goombah and [ __ ] like
that which
and we were drinking them and i went to
his house
i went to this moron's house
and
he's telling me how he's going to new
york and he just got a [ __ ] ounce of
coke
and blah blah blah he's going to a
concert well if you're going to a
concert that means his apartment's going
to be free for three [ __ ] hours i'm
the wrong guy to be i got three hours to
get in here wash dishes i can make a
meal by the time you get back
so i went to piss he was weighing the
coke talking to his girlfriend on the
phone and i excused myself to piss and i
opened up the bathroom window you know
those little back because bathroom
windows you always leave them open in
jersey
people always have their bathroom window
open it's where they're not gonna fit in
those [ __ ] i was gonna say
aren't they really small they're small
but this window i could fit at that time
i was 180. you know what i'm saying i
could fit in any [ __ ] window
especially if there's an ounce of coke
in there i'm like a [ __ ] rat
my spine flattens out i can [ __ ] zip
through a houdini door just look at your
shoulder a little bit i left the
bathroom window open
i go back out he's still on the phone
remember when the phone had the long
cord he was like in the kitchen weighing
coke talking to his girlfriend
and all of a sudden [ __ ]
he gets a knock on the door and like 10
people come over to buy blow and
everybody goes into the bathroom like
everybody has to pee
so at least i had an alibi i'm like oh
[ __ ] ten people in there then like three
other people went in there so i left and
i'm talking to my body and i didn't say
nothing to my buddy my buddy was a crime
stopper
and i knew he was a rap but he was the
only one that was with me that night and
i said you know what i gotta take a walk
i'm going to see if he's i didn't tell
him that he was going to new york
i said because i i don't think they
liked each other so i couldn't walk in
there with this kid so i said you know
what let me go in there
and see if he's there i went back
knocked on the door hey are you there i
may believe he was inside he wouldn't
open i went around the back of the
window it was wide open i jumped in
landed on the bathtub on my shoulder
i went through that apartment for a
[ __ ] hour
and couldn't find that coke i found like
200 cash in like a [ __ ] ring
as i'm walking out i go wait a second
that coke is in there
i went in the kitchen i opened up to
under the sink and there it was in the
tupperware container waiting for uncle
joey
like a cookie waiting for santa on
christmas [ __ ] night you know saying
so i'm living with a dude
we rob him friday and we stay out the
whole weekend
we get sleep on sunday night monday
we're lifting weights
and all of a sudden me and this dude
like brothers are lifting weights and we
hear a knock on the door and it's the
kid with his guerrilla brother
and they're like listen we got to talk
to you and my buddy's like what he goes
friday night you came in my house and he
left the bathroom window open you robbed
me [ __ ] and my friends like i
didn't rob you so i'm in the room
lifting weights laughing my ass off
because out of all the people that
picked they picked my best friend yeah
and he's like get the [ __ ] out of here
before i knock you and your gorilla
brother my friend was crazy
he comes back in and he's telling me all
this and i'm howling deep down inside
because i'm the one that robbed him and
he's like they're accusing me and after
about six minutes he's like
did you [ __ ] rob him it had to be you
how the how the [ __ ] did you rob him and
i'm getting the blame
it took him like a year to figure out it
was me and every time he'd see my buddy
my buddy would go
are you [ __ ] crazy
so once he's he's a thorough
investigator oh my god i figured it out
it's staying on the case once again
he never stopped but it's not that he's
it's not that he's asking me for the
money now it's how he writes the emails
to me like yeah you don't understand
at that point in my life i was just a
mechanic i had to get a job at a store
to pay the debt
the guy charged me a vig
and but i everybody that i would say oh
my god everybody that would see
somewhere in the night would go oh my
god i bumped into what's his name
dog it was the funniest thing for an
hour he told me how you robbed him and
he had to get a part-time job at
woolworths or some [ __ ]
i'm gonna go to hell for those [ __ ]
things you know what i'm saying but who
gives a [ __ ] you gotta have a good time
mickey goal i love how joey gives his
stories you just never relate to him
it's like yeah i just don't have one
like that
i didn't i didn't rob anyone you got a
ton of stories yeah yeah but uh but like
not like
right off of what you say like usually
someone could say i'm like oh yeah i
could relate to that like this and have
a story similar if you're like yeah i
was up in a tree we robbed these bags we
jumped out hit him over the head
i'm like yeah nah i never did that
i always thought growing up
that everybody in new jersey had grown
up the same nah like i always said you
know like everybody's like i used to go
down the shore and there were some crazy
people yeah down the shore when i was
growing up it was crazy and they had to
be crazy because gorillas like me came
down every summer and invaded their
[ __ ] property like we owned the place
they'd park in front of your house call
us bennies yeah i don't know what they
call it ben benny's
right he's a shore boy he's a he's uh
what's betty mean
elizabeth newark new york
benny
so we're benny's yeah we're like
north jersey north jersey new york
people we're bennies where they're like
they're like we're shoebees like we're
not the locals you know they don't like
us
interesting yeah
i didn't know that [ __ ] yeah
i heard the show is completely different
now i didn't even it depends it depends
you got the
you know you got those people like those
some of the crazy people but it's also a
lot of like families the people who stay
down there during the winter that's the
real deal yeah they don't give a [ __ ]
yeah yeah they got a pill they're tough
people down yeah they are tough people
it's like him he's like they have their
natural little like south jersey muay
thai i'm like how you guys know how to
fight like
you know what i mean like no training
just they you know they surf or they
punch each other
nobody surfs right they no they yeah
they do
i never saw people surfing when i was
growing up in jersey you get beat up
like if somebody saw you surfing like
come here
what are you wearing dog what are you
wearing why you dressed like a seal
so what do you think brother about what
about anything what's going on with your
world life's good man
chilling training training hard or it'd
be someone up in a sometime in the
summer hopefully one of the cards that
did they what have they announced lately
um international fight week and stuff is
like in july that's where like they do
like two they do two big cards right
that was like ufc 200 last year
um
i don't know there's there's stuff you
know it's usc there's stuff all the time
no but they just
did they announced mcgregor against
tyrone no mcgregor's going to find
mayweather
first he's going to fight me for sure
and any that probably won't happen until
like after the summer
well they said they booked something in
july at that arena where ufc yeah
from mayweather
i've heard that i've heard i read it i
think
yeah but i don't see how
yeah
i know you're talking about maybe that's
the announcement or something i
understand dana letting them fight but i
if i was dating i'd go before you fight
mayweather you gotta give me one
that's what i was hoping you gotta give
me what pick a [ __ ] tyrone
woodley i think the money is too much
it's not happening
balls seems to be in like conor's court
with it you know what i mean
because if they're both gonna get a
hundred million to just show it's gonna
be the biggest fight in like
combat sports like biggest boxing fight
biggest mma fight it'll be this it'll be
both be big
brings two worlds together hopefully
they hopefully they'll have like an
undercard with a little bit of both a
little boxing a little bit of
mma yo can you imagine they did a
kickboxing if they really agree in the
middle like we're doing it on on on
mayweather's terms the way they're gonna
do it and in a real fight connor stomps
them conor will kill him in like a real
fight
kickboxing and then boxing you know
connor's have his work cut out for
mayweather's uh is a master defensive
genius you know he's not get doesn't get
hit much
so i say they meet in the middle and do
kickboxing let him have some kicks
but mayweather would never go for that
it's his way the highway
because he's smart like you said like
we're talking about fork he's calculated
he's smart you know what i mean
well he said it he goes for a long time
i was the b side
then i went and beat pacquiao now i'm
the [ __ ] a side yeah so you
know now i get to call my [ __ ] shots
here and that happens in everything that
happens for everything
connor's doing it here's my question
mickey because yeah
mayweather is 49 and now and he has all
the money in the world and i know 100
another 100 million is great yeah but to
risk
50-0 like like that's why i think he
won't i'll tell you this like will you
risk that like that seems like once you
start building that up i would think
about
it you listen to the million dollars
and this is the best boxing fight he's
going to get
he doesn't want to fight one of those he
retired he retired he doesn't want to
fight one of these killers like he's you
know he he got canelo young you know
there's all these other guys that will
give him a real boxing fight but he's
taking an mma fighter and putting him in
his
you know his arena no i'm i have no
boxing experience are they looking at
mcgregor the way they were looking at cm
punk versus you do you think like is
that is it that level of disrespect or
what do you think they think mcgregor is
that's
something hard to say i say mcgregor
mcgregor no mcgregor poses
on the real mcgregor po
poses way more of a threat than cm punk
i mean
obviously you know right yeah like he's
like he's a legit he's a great fighter
but
yeah i don't know i bet they they see a
lot of things they think they can expose
because
every every boxing commentator who comes
on tv is just like he stands zero chance
and that makes
i don't understand how that makes he's i
mean he has a puncher chance can't we
see the chance okay but it's it's not a
it's on paper it it floyd should be a
massive female what weight would they
fly that because i'm going to guess
around 55 which for conor 55 that's
that's what i'm what i'm going to guess
i can't remember exactly maybe look up
exactly what floyd fights i i'm not sure
he's like he's somewhere 40s 50s
see that's going to be the interesting
thing we know connor's got great hands
for sure we know that he's got great
hands connor has great kicks too i
understand but that's never going to
[ __ ] happen i know okay no i'm not
i'm not talking about you anymore i'm
just saying a thing that makes him so
great at mma is not just his hands it's
his kicks no it's his case but i'm
talking about if he fights mayweather
yeah of course what's the whole thing
mayweather's a master yes of getting a
defensive but he's also how old
40
that makes a difference
not really maybe your eyes your movement
you got that is he for i mean he's such
a [ __ ] great athlete sure but i don't
think the eighth you're doing this
you know i've been here maybe you know
i'd love to see it but one part of me i
want to see connor in the ufc you know
like for sure i'd rather i'd rather see
him fight the 55 i'm a purist man and i
don't like when they start
[ __ ] around that's why i've been
disenchanted
in the ufc with the last two or three
years i get it i totally [ __ ] around
too much
i like the purist [ __ ] number one fights
number two if he don't want to fight him
then give it to somebody else and that
number one gets relinquished yeah
whether you're having a kid whether your
mother's dying it doesn't matter you got
to fight yeah you can't take off two
[ __ ] years you're injured i'm with
you i'm with you you know but once you
like i've said a thousand times once you
start doing things for one person
you have to do them for another
and that's when okay yeah yeah yeah
that's what that's what jim miller's
saying
he's saying you're holding up the whole
155 uh division
but you won't let anyone i ca jim's like
i can't go fight a kickboxing match
he's like but they'll let conor do
special stuff
that's his that's his words fights
but you uh most people knew that they're
not allowed to do that if clanna fights
whatever his name is
floyd yeah for 100 million dollars sure
dana white's taking a piece oh
absolutely they're getting a pizza
they're facilitating yeah yeah they're
not getting them out of there that's
what gets him out of his next fight in
the ufc that's why i think it's it's
smart for ufc to do it why not
it's smart it's it's a thousand things i
can't call it it's a big fight it's it's
history i think so he's been fighting at
welterweight in his last few fights so
which is what wait uh i believe it's 51.
i mean let me look it up but i do think
that conor's like a good size bigger
than floyd like connor would be coming
down 55 and floyd would be eating to get
up to 55.
so that that's another thing that can
make this a little more fun than it
being the master versus a guy who's
fighting outside his sport
you know
and i think chronically hit hard
heck yeah chanukah left hands though and
conically it kind of has a great chance
against
mayweather not just a puncher's chance
connor's got a good chin
i i
who do you think that's that's tougher
for connor after like five rounds it
becomes something different but three
minute rounds he's used to fives he's
done five fives
and he seems now the ring's a little
bigger than the octagon correct
um lengthwise and floyd knows how to use
that ring yes absolutely his advantage
that's gonna be that's huge the the
terrain you're fighting off yeah it's
the brain
that's sun tzu stuff there's a lot of
different things involved there that
let's see if it even happens let's see
if it even [ __ ] happens yeah who
knows i hate like predicting what's
going to happen what's the weightly 147.
you
see that's a
that's a toughy right there yeah he'll
come back to toughie
you think floyd will come up yeah
hearing 47 confirms what i thought what
does floyd walk around that
floyd
that's what i'm saying he's [ __ ]
boxers boxers don't do the tremendous
weight cuts mma fighters do they like
they're on weight on that week in camp
they stay training at their fight week
why don't ufc fighters do that or mma
because
mma has a huge wrestling influence and
wrestling you suck as much weight down
as possible and make yourself as light
as possible so you have a size advantage
you could be the bigger man stronger man
you know
but if everyone's doing it exactly but
night so now ever you're right
everyone's doing it so everyone needs to
do it just to keep up right yeah exactly
you know
yeah
what a wild [ __ ] world we live in
yeah i never thought i would see [ __ ]
people in a cage kicking and wrestling
yeah and there you have it
it's become a [ __ ] uh a [ __ ]
thrill
too it's all right it's a thrill man and
you're right there in it you're right
you're going in at the right time you're
young
you got the world by the ball you got
nothing to lose right yeah
[ __ ] all that i get to fight get to go
on and fight in front of them by now
they'd already give you a [ __ ] fight
but it takes time
they want to see what's going on july is
still
july seems like a long time away but
it's really nice
yeah it's right there
it's so weird how i
i get to stay home from may 13th to june
20 [ __ ] third
that's like five weeks continuously i'd
never do that [ __ ] yeah
but i have so many places gonna be like
my training camp to stand up yeah like
that's where i sit down for five weeks
and really chase work at the store and
stuff
i work everywhere oh you go okay all
right cool yeah you got it right when
you go to the store it's like fighting
in the ufc now yeah you got to bring
your a game when you go to the store and
we were there
yeah and to bring your a game down there
it's [ __ ] tough all the time you know
you want to experiment i like to
experiment so i go down to smokers
okay yeah
sidekicks and i can work on my spinning
back kick and i can like nobody knows
nothing go yeah go down to the little
box
so i try to do the south black kids in
there yeah yeah last night i went to
flappers
you know uh
tomorrow night i'm an oxnard and but
next week
like tuesday i'll go to a different
place there's a room that they're
telling me around the corner here yeah
there's a [ __ ] place an insurance
place they turn into a stand-up comedy
place next to the sushi place with the d
rating
right there by 7-eleven by the police
station sushi plays with d-rating did
they get any [ __ ] business
i would never listen for six dollars
food poisoning dog i went there two
times and i and i left there you go
there if you got weight to drop he wants
to lose some quick weight vomiting
like one day let me see if these people
got business
me and lee went in there didn't you go
in there with me yeah you brought me in
there after i can't believe you're
accusing me of wholesale sushi well the
first time it wasn't bad it was close by
i didn't go on yelp i took a chance
it wasn't
nobody got sick
nobody got sick it wasn't they gave you
four items on the menu
for like six bucks
in a california row
and as you're reading it you're like
this is two day-old sushi but i'm gonna
live i swam in the hudson this ain't no
big thing isn't it isn't the name like
sonny's or something sunny deez that
isn't like a jewish old man's name it's
a jewish old man with two mexicans
working they don't know it's liquor
[ __ ] english
but let me tell you something they're
out there
under a highway
oh my gosh
okay they're under a highway
the corner 10 feet away is rat infested
dumpster
and do you know what they have sidewalk
eating
and there's people out there like it's
[ __ ] paris france it's alfresco yeah
it's al fresco between the pollution and
there's times i go to that 7-eleven
i don't want to go home there's a
7-eleven there's a 7-eleven a dry
cleaner a bartending school
all right so they have a bartender in
school there
and people go in there and drink
really like from eight to ten that's
what they do so they want to train you
so neighborhood people go in there and
get like a beer for like a dollar
you learn how to get a beer how to open
it and [ __ ] like that that's hysterical
you're gonna mix it greyhound
and then they gonna go to the sushi
place with the d rating and they eat
their hearts on they're out there you
know talking about gluten and
world peace and hillary clinton should
have done it
but meanwhile they're eating d [ __ ]
sushi
it's hysterical but next to that
that we used to be an all-state place
and now
some kid cleaned it out put a stage in
them and chairs
and for two bucks you go up there and
they'll let you go on stage
and they run till like three in the
[ __ ] morning
that's why i'm scared to go to that
7-eleven now every time i go in there
see it's different comedian hey what are
you doing what am i doing what are you
doing
you're in the [ __ ] corner over there
with rats
is that the green room with the rats
no that's just a little room over there
but that's really cool you know how many
times i've parked it i've gone in there
like at one in the morning
just to get like a soda and and no
smoking gum or a lighter and i'll sit
there
and within eight minutes i'll see a rat
the size of my [ __ ] arm
right there 20 feet away and that's when
i run in the car like a little [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i [ __ ] hate rats
i don't like those like vermin animals
like i don't like like in uh we went to
rutgers in new brunswick they have like
these ballsy ass pigeons or you'll be
walking and a pigeon like won't move for
you so like you have to you end up
finding yourself walking out of the way
i'm like i know i'll take out a pigeon i
know i'll beat a squirrel but at what
cost like it scratches my face it po
pokes me in the the bird flies up tries
to beat me in the eye so i i do the same
thing i just avoid them i love animals
but i'll kick a pigeon that's what i'm
saying i don't want it i don't want to
have to twist this i don't like those
little [ __ ] lice infested
[ __ ] with their disgusting
feathers [ __ ] and plucking
they're [ __ ] dirty they're dirty man
they're dirty i [ __ ] hate pigeons
with all my heart and [ __ ]
that place starts pitching me too what
place that place that you went that day
that you and paula went i just read the
review they serve [ __ ] pigeon and
poorly he calls me every meal he calls
me and my dad i give my dad a few
options
including stout because i knew i took
him through the joey questions like
what's joey gonna ask if i asked him
okay stout we got him he wanted to go
get some mediterranean because they have
no mediterranean down there in [ __ ]
florida
it's not like that you gotta take a
plane all the way out of here
he calls me and he we go through this
whole 10-minute barrage of he he didn't
even talk to my dad he's like i want to
talk to people who eat hummus and hung
up the phone and my dad's like does he
call you
uh and ask about your meals a lot he's
like every meal i'll give the report of
what i ate oh it's i do it just to just
to shock myself
that's my entertainment whatever his
dinner is yeah that's what my
entertainment is
because there's always a story
he can call me and tell me he's gonna go
get a lobster tail
and he'll call me an hour later and it
completely changed to something
so [ __ ] outlandish
that i won't understand it
i could see if you go nah we didn't want
lobster we wouldn't got fish
but he'll go from like a lobster tail
to like the worst taco place in the
country
he could talk to me about mexican food
and we'll talk about how he loves it he
can't wait to have it and an hour later
he's eaten at a black fried chicken
place and he can't finish the chicken
because it's so [ __ ] bad
this guy goes to pismo eats pizza in
hollywood you go to amoeba you always go
to joe's it's like tradition you go to
joe's no one knows this tradition and
you get pizza when we go to hollywood
where do i take you the last three times
yes okay it's tradition
him and paula love pizza they love bad
pizza
they're an amiibo all they had to do was
walk 30 yards to go to joe's they're not
dirty dirty [ __ ] yards of this
where'd they go they got in their car
and went to the worst fried chicken
place
in the [ __ ] country they couldn't
even recognize they would have done
better with popeyes
we would have it sad it's not the worst
it's supposed to be the best but who
knew
that's what happened you told me not to
use yelp
who hasn't heard roscoe's chicken and
waffles when you're writing on me but
there's only one place to go
and that's joe's pizza i mean you'll
travel two hours to get them next time
i'm gonna call you like no don't follow
me this is p.m just to check right this
is stuff you [ __ ] know off the top of
your head
he went to austin
thank god i stopped him he was going to
all you could eat chinese buffet
who goes to austin to eat chinese food
they would have poisoned them
they would have poisoned them thank god
for bobby sharon to take him to eat
mexican food chewie's chewy i mean you
know it's always mr saya you don't
understand what i live with
today
listen he's happy with blue apron for a
year two weeks ago he what are you doing
i'm at the supermarket buying parmesan
cheese
like what are you cooking spaghetti no
no this company they deliver this stuff
was so bad
they had to throw it away they never got
it again they were so embarrassed
like
i don't take a chance
i'm from jury i don't take chances
there's no reason to take a chance if
that chinese place has a lunch special
for 495
with a diet coke
i go there every day
that's where everybody goes i don't care
if they want to eat greek
sandwiches i don't even pay attention
like i can't eat chinese food that's
great you're eating chinese food today
i don't know nothing
i don't even ask people
like what would you prefer today i don't
give a [ __ ] we're going to get the best
you want to eat the best you want to
[ __ ] suck dick and take a chance and
get sick
tell them mickey golf is when i live
today today feels like the first time
actually meeting lee because although i
was i was here with him last time lee
wasn't here with us me neither
the next morning yo you guys were
popping those things like oh my god
that's why i gave him up for lent oh you
did yeah i gave him up for life this is
the second time
okay
you just got back into it right yeah
yeah but they ain't doing dick nah nah
and i'm pretty happy because i lowered
my tolerance
and now cbd oil is working better for me
yeah and i got my wife hooked on cbdo
which is [ __ ] unbelievable
it's good for you this is great for you
she kept telling me i i don't sleep i'm
up at three in the morning i said that's
over
take the cb deal so for a week she's
been taking a cbd or i take it too
sleeping like a zombo you know what she
said to me tonight at dinner
i looked at the thing there's thc and i
go what the [ __ ] you think you're
dealing with
i you didn't know that that's why you
sleep like a zombo
oh she hers with thc in it oh [ __ ] yeah
that's the only way i do it because it
gets it to the system a lot easier see i
got the stuff they get in jersey is like
it's no i i do use it but it's like it's
not psychoactive there's no thc in it
this isn't psychoactive but if you don't
smoke okay you get something i got i
sent it to my godmother for her hips
okay and she kept calling me and then
she kept saying man took the pain away
but boy i slept 13 hours last night
that's what people want
yeah my buddy just got a shoulder
surgery he's been taking a lot of it too
i take it because it's good for like for
your brain stuff like that i take shots
in the head sometimes so yeah you know
preventative no it's good for brains
it's good for circulation
it's just good you sleep better it's
good for muscle pain like yeah i won't
take the information and all that
because i was actually getting [ __ ]
hungry i gotta get back from jiu jitsu i
popped two tiles i took a gallon of
water and i'll spray three of those
sprays under my tongue and a couple
weeks ago i almost didn't make it to the
[ __ ] podcast it gives you the
munchies let's see the [ __ ] munchies
too
what do you mean you need to make it to
the podcast i don't feel [ __ ] from that
i don't get anything
no no no because you have to get one for
one
that's what it's called there's one for
one
there's two for one then there's no thc
okay but one for one a guy like you has
to do no thc because of the testing
like
dick you could do one for one
so before you leave telly to get you two
bottles or one for one from perennial
there's 64 a piece
and they're [ __ ] tremendous you'll
sleep like a baby can't wait you'll
sleep like a baby
yep
you take it out of the box
you take the label off
you put the cap on it you put it in a
baggie so it doesn't spill
and you put it on the inside of your
shaving kit
if they look in there
i don't think that mother's burning help
you know i'm saying why not look there
for well y'all look at that for they're
going to get business
if they're going to be that creepy
and you and then and they're going to
take it out and read it and it's not
their world guys
so they're really not going to bust your
balls
does this marijuana cbd or just keep
saying a cb deal and if a [ __ ]
scientist comes over and says this has
thc you blame it on lisa yeah my [ __ ]
son that sack of [ __ ]
i told you no thcs played a [ __ ]
trick on me that son of a [ __ ] i'm
never told they're not gonna come back
and throw deleon they might they don't
know no lee they're not going to throw
you in jail because then you're going to
play stupid too and i don't know what
you're talking about my dad his back
hurts and he has [ __ ] headaches
what's the rule number one in the church
you don't know nothing
i don't know nothing you don't know
nothing so he's gonna blame it on you
you're gonna blame it on him it's a big
misunderstanding you've donated a
hundred dollars to the jew federation of
america
for a scholarship to summer camp the
shabbat camp right
yeah what's the shabbat camp what's the
name of it oh yeah
the telethon
i think you're saying shabbat
yeah same difference they do the same
that's awesome but they're not going to
[ __ ] say nothing to you they don't
even know what it is guys
they really don't it's not like they're
trained in cbdo
they're really not they know the [ __ ]
we're still very blind to this still
so if they find that they're gonna ask
you what it is listen there's cbd all
you could spray on your back
and they're free bro you know how many
times my back is hurt like just saw from
going to jiu jitsu
and they have samples at the weed store
you just take them pull up your shirt
and by the time you walk out of there
you got no pain in your back
it feels like you put that freeze on
your back and [ __ ]
nice you know i'm not a thc expert
i might be mickey call no no no
i'm a [ __ ] idiot compared to other
people
but i know how things make me feel and i
know how it affected my wife
my wife don't get high tonight she was
giggling she's like that's got t.h.c in
it you [ __ ]
that's why the other night i couldn't
tell who you was she said she got up in
the middle of night
and she didn't know who the [ __ ] you
were for like 10 minutes
she goes i didn't know if you [ __ ]
went to sleep and she that's how high
she's getting but last couple weeks ago
i did five sprays and i got up at four
to pee
the room was purple it's like that time
i did ecstasy and woke up in the middle
of night i took an x-men went home fell
asleep i got up to pee in the middle of
night the room was [ __ ] purple
what's going on dog you just said kill
him man chilling chilling can't relate
to that making you don't want to talk to
me about nothing oh you know i love
talking to you man talk to me um where
do you go to jiu jitsu where is this
place uh david dives it's uh gracie new
jersey it's in lebanon new jersey how
far from
uh harry what's his name the [ __ ] guy
that harry the guy that fought in the
ufc that has henry new jersey he's got
the jiu jitsu
uh are you talking about nikkitone
no no no nicotone jim miller uh ricardo
almeida ricardo almeida has a school in
henry new jersey
hamilton hamilton henry i don't know
whether for something
yeah hamilton hamilton henry they both
sing yeah it's a great school i uh i'm
it's a little far from me though okay
yeah
my mind is that mine's a great school
too david is the man
yeah it
what is it gib and nogi mostly ghee
actually
a lot of games and you teach with the
game yeah yeah i love the ghee i love
the ghee too i like the the shorts but i
don't get it the gi's a fun game if you
can get out of arm bars and everything
with all that friction the ghee your
nogi my defense is so i slip out of
anything you know what i mean really
yeah what your it makes your nogi
defense so good because with with gee it
slows it down you have to be calculated
you have to use the right moves you can
just use little pulls and bursts and you
slip out of stuff because of the because
of the the lack of friction like the
slippery the sweat the keys slow all
that stuff down so it's a toe it's it's
a really different game
i love it i love it too i'm so bad at it
and i love it really
you're putting in the work though man
you got him back into it real big time
you look at him he's all skin remember
he's getting a little soft he's out here
and cali eating way too many avocados
you know getting a little chubby soft
around the edges now look at him man i
am hooked like a drug addict i think
that
if i don't go i could tell the
difference on stage
i could tell the difference in my home
like when i go and i get choked out
and let's say i do one good thing but i
get kicked five times i focus on what i
did good man yeah so i leave there
feeling great i don't focus on it i got
choked up by a 26 year old kid i don't
you know he passed my guard i had him in
half guard for a little while you know
we tried to [ __ ] around he's a purple
belt i never wrestled before so
everything to me was from scratch all
those muscles that you need were i had
to develop from scratch so the first
year was just getting my elbow strong
learning how to post
learning how to [ __ ] get up on one
knee you know i was 340 and going in
there and huffing and puffing
paranoid with a i had the panic attacks
being on the bottom look at how good
it's making you look now no you're
coming down man you're what you you're
you're getting out of line and that's
the way to get it looking is to go in
there i go in there a little earlier i
go in there 45 minutes earlier and i do
all the warming up [ __ ] on my own
so by the time i get on the mat i have
fire one of these guys i can breathe
easier i won't go into panic mode go
smart i do the wall
so you don't get hurt yeah i'll keep you
on the mat listen i'm 54. yeah it's the
warmer you need as long as the workout
if you don't [ __ ] think so you're
gonna pop something the warm-up has to
be i do very long warm-ups achilles
tendons i jump rope
i [ __ ] do sit-ups push-ups he's got
those rings
and i just twist them i pull my hips up
and i pull myself up i breathe in and
then i let my hips go down i do five
sets of ten of those good we're gonna
engage all those muscles get them all
fired by the end of that i'm already
sweating with that rash guard on i'm
taking my g-top off i take those steel
bats i work my shoulders i do the
[ __ ] push-ups i stretch my back i
mean i just do it so when by the time i
go in there i go through all that
dizziness
and all that you should stay home yeah
call resistance you become a [ __ ] i
shouldn't have come i ate at eight
thirty maybe i realized you're walking
in and you're like yeah oh my god you
did i still get that sometimes dog i was
telling i gotta get hypnotized for fear
have you ever turned around though every
time you walk in right you did actually
turn around one time i pulled up parked
before i went to alberto cranes the
first time i went the first time all
right that doesn't i say that doesn't
count then i went on a saturday pulled
the car up parked
sat there for 10 minutes
started the car and went
and i was so pissed starting is the
hardest thing i was so
pissed at myself that whole weekend like
that sunday i got up and i tried to
redeem myself
by going all the schools like where else
can i go today and i said [ __ ] it i'm
going monday
and when i walked in there just doing
the warm-up
my [ __ ] heart was in my throat yeah i
remember the first my first day i was
talking about wanting to do jiu jitsu i
was 16 and then my dad found a place it
was a sunday he was like come on let's
go you're talking about this whole time
let's go we're going i'm taking you to
that and i was like nah i don't want to
go because like it's weird it's a weird
thing you're like you're a little
nervous about it you know but it's the
hardest that's why we say the hardest
part is starting just get for people who
like trying thinking about it
just you got to just go in it's the
hardest part we just gotta do it i take
my daughter to school by 8 45 i get home
i send some emails i make some calls
by 9 45 i start getting nervous
yeah
that's when my body starts telling me
you know what it's a sunny day why don't
you just work out at home and get some
vitamin d
you're going to be locked in the gym
sniffing balls and feet yeah with a
[ __ ] guillotine that's what all
i mean it's just you get all this fear
coming into you as i'm making my [ __ ]
protein drink and as i'm filling my
little water flask
i'm talking myself out of a dog like ah
i'll go tomorrow i go tonight at 6 30
before the podcast
oh my god and then after i shake up the
protein drink and i take my little asper
from my heart i go i gotta go
yeah i go put undies on knee pads you
know like [ __ ] go and yeah
so you feel so much better after right
as soon as you walk in you're gonna hate
yourself all day if you skip it and
you're gonna feel good about yourself
all day if you go it's three hours of my
week it's therapy it's like it's there's
absolutely yeah yeah and every time i go
i try to last a little longer i try not
to tap out that's it man you know i just
try to uh
so it just it i wanted to do something
beside comedy comedy wasn't cutting it
for me in that sense you know i don't
have a great time when i go to a comedy
club and see 20 comics anymore
it's your your little it's jaded
for a little bit
okay i've been doing it for too long so
i enjoy seeing some comedians yeah but
other ones i could do without and you
probably you gotta like they all want to
talk to you no no
[Music]
if you go to mark henry's gym
you got five ufc guys and that's a lot
of [ __ ] testosterone yeah yeah that's
the tones that's uh down the shoulders
it's a lot of [ __ ] testosterone
even if i love mickey a little bit of
testosterone yeah i feel like mickey
shows me uh
a a takedown you know a single a
different way for joey to do a single
and while he's teaching me i do it on
him i do a little harder
you know it's just just little things
that so with comics now that i go down
there i know where we stand
i just want to do my business and get
out of there so my therapy is when i go
to jiu jitsu
and nobody knows who the [ __ ] i am
i sit in the back i'm that fat [ __ ] his
face is getting red
during the warm ups and doing the hip
slides you know the hip escapes and [ __ ]
but then after that whole thing i tie on
my belt and
i remember when i started i would go to
the fundamental class
and go to myself i hope i never get
promoted to the advanced class yeah
like i don't ever want to go to the
advanced class i'll stay in this [ __ ]
fundamental class
until i'm 90.
because it's like they break it down
more you only roll once but you break
the guard for like 15 or 20 minutes
the other side you break the guard for
10 minutes then for the last 20 or so
you roll eight-minute rounds i didn't
want to do that long rounds that's good
eight minutes yeah oh no no that's a
long [ __ ] time for a long round i'm
an old man yeah most champions do five
that's that i like that i kind of like
that yeah it's kind of it's kind of
weird but yeah you know what i go i
dread it but when i walk out that door
if a car hits me god forbid he'll bounce
off me
that's how you feel because you overcame
the hardest thing that you wanted to do
that day whether it's write a letter
whether it's apologize to somebody it's
all the same [ __ ] feeling you get the
same that nervousness that uncomfortable
that's good for you though that's really
good it's you know strong
yeah you know i get hypnotized for my
fear yeah for when i when i start
huffing and puffing i can't control my
heart rate okay and it sends me
somewhere like i get anxiety
i gotta really control it and control my
breathing and slow down my heart rate so
i started getting hypnotized and i was
telling her that
the problem with my jiu jitsu and my
comedy was the same approach i was going
over there all fired up like it was like
it was comedy jiu jitsu isn't comedy
if i go fired up into jiu jitsu i'm
gonna burn out just thinking about it
when i shake mickey's hand and i look
and see his black belt i already lost
that's the type of guy i am i just wait
for you to [ __ ] do whatever you can
because i'm scared of you
that's how i would do it now at least
i don't have that fear no more it's not
about the belt it's about the technique
getting me moving around and passing
your guard
so i had little fears if you passed my
guard and got on top of me
i couldn't breathe yeah i didn't want to
have that
i wanted to
just now i had an altercation i told you
guys not an altercation but i had to
yell at somebody because they were just
trying to be johnny [ __ ]
tough in front of him
and i remember walking into the weed
store
and my anxiety was starting to come up
but i controlled it and i even turned
around looked back at him
and he walked into his [ __ ] car i
couldn't do that years ago
i would [ __ ] lose it like i and i
don't want to lose it
so i wanted to tell her i was telling i
want to keep the fear for comedy
but i want you to take away the fear for
jiu jitsu yeah do you follow me for
comedy it's like fighting
you've been doing forever you're gonna
get up there you know you're gonna yeah
i know i'm gonna get up there
but you still have should have a little
fear you need to have that it's got to
be sharp keep yourself if you're walking
into the octagon and you're 30 feet away
you have to have
a right fear and then it converts into a
certain type of energy yeah that fear
becomes what
potential and adrenaline is energy
that's stored and kinetic energy is
energy that moves
it's so [ __ ] weird how this works in
your body and unless you've been on
stage
you really and you've been on the radio
you know lee's been on stage
it's a euphoric [ __ ] thing
because at first as you're walking
towards it it's like you're walking to
get shot
that's how i feel when there's times
that there's shows and there's 600
people in the audience and i have
friends in the audience i'd rather you
shoot me
as i'm walking up but once you touch
that microphone
and you say those first couple words
whatever was in your stomach
those butterflies and that fart that
gets stuck in your ass you ever get
those nervous farts it pushes your [ __ ]
out and it just smells horrible like it
smells like your intestines are in the
room i'll fart sometimes before i go on
stage like just
his heart like a nervous fart like i'll
get a little coat of sweat on me like
anxiety sweat i'll feel that it's so
many weirds how that energy transcends
in you once i touch the microphone
though
and i say those first couple words
that energy goes on to the audience and
now i have no fear
how does time work for you guys like
what i mean like
in in terms of what does it go faster so
when i went on stage sometimes it seemed
like five minutes took forever and
sometimes 30 seconds went by no in no
time at all
like how does it work for you guys how
does how does it work in the ring i'm
curious that's a great question
um i i guess it's a lot of it's just
like autopilot like i you don't hear a
lot of your corner you're you're just
kind of locked in like in in the cage in
the fight i always tell people like
amateurs or people before they fight i'm
like yo it's it's different in there i
remember my my friend uh
billy d williams he told me he was like
yo just you'll see it's different in
there and it's different because you're
it's it's just very every everything's
heightened
you know it's like you you're uh you're
very locked in you're very uh
like tunnel vision
so time is like you kind of have an idea
aware maybe here your corner i'll hear
little bits and pieces
um not everything probably i mean you
know what i mean i just like i hear
spots of what they're saying and then
you know i hear i hear the last 10
seconds you have an idea just from
because you're always doing five minute
rounds but
not like you know so
when i when i meant more ways like does
it seem like it takes longer than five
minutes at for some rounds yeah
sometimes yeah it could seem every it's
weird it's one of those things where
it's like it seems very fast and it's
also forever at the same time well if
you're getting punched in the head
forever
if you're punching the [ __ ] that
[ __ ] goes by quick and [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying but if you're getting
hit in the head i can imagine that even
that [ __ ] doesn't like hurt like it no
no you're just like it's just like oh
it's like you're just kidding it's like
a video game you know you're just like
bomb okay that's the thing yeah no once
you go back and the adrenaline goes out
and the pain starts okay i guess i got
hit
oh my god jesus christ
i would i i
i thought that you guys would zero in
more on the trainer
like all you would hear is his voice
like throughout those eight weeks of
training camp
he was yelling so much some some people
i bet you but i've also frost frost
hobby said that you shouldn't be really
hearing much he said you should be so
locked in that you
that you shouldn't you should be tunnel
vision you should just be seeing your
guy and you should be locked in
shouldn't really be here much you know
and
you i have people that come up to me
before shows excuse me mr diaz
it's uh
it's my myself and my wife's
anniversary my name is bob it's johnson
and my wife's name is eleanor johnson
when you go up there tonight can you
give us a shout out
people have no idea
that once i hit the stage
your name and you i'm thinking about the
last thing i think about it
it's so [ __ ] weird
like you don't even think about you
don't even remember that [ __ ]
if i don't see you
you're dead
like you come up to me and go there's
three bachelorette parties in the show
i won't even remember when i'm getting
up there yeah i don't have time to
remember your [ __ ] name and your
wedding like when people contact me and
say hey during your show
can you do not even in a million [ __ ]
years i think you purposely forget
what's that
any of that information no i don't
purposely forget you [ __ ] forget if
you're doing your job
you [ __ ] forget
if you're focused in on what you're
doing and your materials coming from
your heart you're not thinking about
mary or bob johnson unless they're your
[ __ ] parents and they're in the
audience and they're watching you bomb a
dire slow death
that's when you'll get a [ __ ]
sympathy hug by going listen my parents
have been married for 80 years and
they're in the audience tonight and the
crowd goes crazy and now you got a
little daylight i'm saying
you follow them saying to you
so yeah that's the only time you'll
remember if you're dying so bad
that you'll go okay here's my chance to
be nice guy or you'll thank the troops
let's give it up for the troops as soon
as they say let's give it up for the
troops you're dead
okay and i respect the troops i'm not
saying nothing bad about the troops but
that's what those are usually i give a
waitress a shout out
you know yeah it's like a crotch like if
i'm getting a beating
i'll give i'll tell them to tip the
waitresses which in fighting is like
going back to the corner and your coach
telling you what to do i'm programmed to
tell you about the waitresses
but in my mind i'm thinking about what
are the next two bits coming at you i
gotta dig deep [ __ ] this this [ __ ]
little joke about the waitresses is
ending in 10 seconds what's coming out
of your mouth your mind's going yeah
your mind's going a million it's really
[ __ ] weird it's really
just weird like i love when a fighter
would go this i'm gonna go in there
punch him in the face
and on bomb and you go what
that's a taste of tremendous focus
to go into a fight knock a [ __ ] dude
out get on top and spin him an arm bomb
for no reason
that takes a tremendous focus it it
takes the same amount of focus
to go on stage and try to like do 55
like i tell people all the time people
come up to me and go hey do you want to
party after the show listen to me
after the show
the adrenaline wears
so those two hours of standing
me sinking into the [ __ ] stage
because when i'm on stage my gorilla
feet
sink into the stage
you guys don't see it because i wear a
size 13 but i got a size 14 adidas so i
can make my feet clamp into the floor
these are the same things that fighters
do
it's the same [ __ ] day
so after the first show i go back there
and sit down can you imagine rolling for
an hour and then making me you sit down
for an hour getting cold and then going
back out there that's the toughest
show of the week it's the second show
right that's interesting so now your
energy has to be at a complete different
level
you got to get
really want to get the energy twice so
what i usually do is loosen up with
people in the room not do my jokes on
them but pick an argument
you follow me
something like i'll torture liam but
what the [ __ ] you eating even if i like
what he's eating
i'll ask him what he's eating just to
engage him
into getting me hyped again lee doesn't
know i'm doing it he has no [ __ ] idea
i'm doing it
you know rogan and redband knew
they would put their phones on the table
i didn't believe and men should have
matching phones at that time
okay so they used to all have matching
phones
i would look at those phones and the
heat in my heart
would burn up and i would go on stage
like a killer
you know it's so many
people have no idea what really happens
i can't party after a show yeah two
hours of standing it feels like i've
been running for four hours it sounds
like you're
expanding your energy in the proper
places yeah it shouldn't be crazy you
know as we say if you're working hard
enough in the gym you shouldn't have the
energy to be going out and
[ __ ] around you know
my hips don't hurt my hips are great i
exercise my hips all the time when i get
off stage these two points appear from
your energy coming from your [ __ ] nut
sack
that energy comes deep from the [ __ ]
nut sack it's kind of travel through
those capillaries and those chakras as
they say
you know what i'm saying i gotta drop
chakras and these [ __ ] for these
non-acupuncture [ __ ] that cali
talk that's that cali what's up lee drop
it on me baby boy
you guys want to split this in the acid
you're ready to go lisa what let's see
what science go hard man
i'm impressed like father like son
listen we ain't got time to [ __ ] around
when the science are doing that thing
this diets are doing their [ __ ] thing
okay
i said i think we're gonna stick with
the weed tonight jesus christ um no
let's give him a piece of blood what do
you think jesus decided he wants a
little bit [ __ ] yeah anybody
legally listen if it was what up the
lead tank
if it was up to lee you guys would be at
a shitty movie right now
you know what i'm saying watching the
movie
dying inside like eating squirrels [ __ ]
eating squirrel tacos
if it was up to lee
i'm not going to tell you what
what
it's intense you won't sleep tonight but
fighting comes family late asleep what
do you think he's you
he'll be up all three nights bopping and
shoving he don't give a [ __ ] jack
we'll save this for you for 4 20.
we'll have the asset for you tomorrow
we'll meet him do a pregame
we'll do a pregame periscope and we'll
give you a little ice cube to take with
you to go not be new new time
and we'll put pink floyd music on yeah
you'll think you never want to be
outside or do you want does it make you
want to be alone in the dark room
well
it's all up to you only one way to find
out there's only one way to find out me
i would drop you off at the house
turn off the lights and put on pink
floyd and just sit there and watch your
life flash in front of you
put on the wall and let it go then put
on animals
then take it the dark side of the moon
then wish you were here then by that
time
leo will be checking your pulse
calling the rabbi and [ __ ] by the way
speaking of rabbis
i was watching a [ __ ] show about
panama i have a friend that's panamanian
and i was watching that show with don
zimmerman where he showed he
wanted me and all this [ __ ]
and panama do me a favor
just open that door a little bit
don't block the cameras don't block the
cameras just open the door a little bit
jesus christ on the crutch
what happened
my girl bladder is acting up a little
bit i'm about to pee in a little while
good you will you need to pee
i'll do the [ __ ] shout outs real
quick and [ __ ] here
you know i love you [ __ ] with
all my heart
mickey go on the house
tyler kaufman
don wrangler
dante cassini writing more letters than
abe lincoln
brandy lynn one by one podcast
i don't know who the [ __ ] this is wes
woods and my man lorenzo
toledo what are you [ __ ] nuts or what
micah
garcia how's that one for you bad
[ __ ] how was that all right
that's good i'm really now at this point
right now that you don't have a fight
how many days a week are you training
uh five
five yes
and set more than once a day
so what do you do what's your typical
monday monday i uh a box at like two
i'll do boxing a little kickboxing i'll
do that from like two to like 4 30. then
i'll chill and i'll do
i'll i'll do jiu jitsu and the ghee from
six to seven thirty and i'll do nogi
from 7 30 to like
10
pretty much monday monday's a nice big
day
that's like that's like first is two and
a half second sessions like
four so i'm doing like six and a half
hours of training
and what's uh
what do you do tuesday tuesday i do
strain the conditioning
and then
i'll uh
like i'll go i'll go to the gym work out
with my man uh billy d williams that'd
be on fitness and uh like lately i've
been doing a lot of squats and deadlifts
just like yeah yeah eating everything
that lips is tremendous yeah just
feeling strong and getting strong
is just strength and conditioning there
yes
just one day and then wednesday
i'll uh i'll do
the gi jiu jitsu and then i spar
so i'm doing uh like more stand up you
know
thursday thursday i strain i i strain
the condition again and then i'll do
a geek class again and then friday i i
uh
i do boxing and kickboxing
and then and sprinkle it in there on my
strengthening condition days i'll also
hit pads
so i'm doing like this you do a strength
and conditioning tuesday and thursday in
camp i'll add an extra day
um and do like a little more cardio
lately i've been doing more lifting but
on tuesdays and thursdays i'm going to
be working on my man armor who is uh
always in jim miller's corner good muay
thai pat on herself and i'll be you know
hit some miss with him so you you're
pretty much if you had a fight how much
weight would you have to cut right now
right now i'm i'm big i'm like but at 70
i make 70 really easy which is why i
felt comfortable you know putting on a
little bit of weight
and uh i'm like 200 right now
yeah a strong man feels strong well
that's what happens when you gain that
weight it depends what type of muscle
you build yeah i've been i've been
working real hard like we went we went
to london for the ufc
and like when i was out there we had fun
like you know drank almost every night
and [ __ ] but before that i put in like a
camp like doing two a days monday to
friday sometimes sparring up in miller's
on on sunday early in the morning like
just getting work in like putting a lot
of work in and then i took like a week
off when i was in london and then i've
been back at it again just training hard
as heck
trying to change i'm supposed to train
with bisping out here but he uh he's in
thailand filming a movie
this is tremendous that you guys
a lot of people at home just think you
guys show up they don't know [ __ ] know
how [ __ ] hard it is year round
that's the thing why i compare it
so much
to uh
to calmly in a way
totally agree because
we're it's like you don't see all the
work we put in you put in at like the
comedy store this place i'm in the gym
two times a day it's only the it's your
guys specials and my fights so i i got
if i'm not if i don't if i'm not perfect
and for 15 minutes the fifth only 15
minutes that i get people get to see i'm
like a piece of [ __ ] ever you know i
mean then you it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter how hard you work unless
if you go if you can't bring it that one
night that one date that they set you
have to bring it that night or your
garbage you're never going to be
anything in this in that sport
it's crazy because for years
i thought i would just go up there and
uh
you know give it
give it like 50 and whatever happened to
happen yeah that's why i don't like
improvising on stage okay
and for years
my comedy got better after i started
watching mma
really
i tell people i compared it to mma you
know i have heard you talk about that
talked about gsp and yeah well just not
like i compared like
the [ __ ] people don't like to do like
you see a guy come in and he has three
knockouts
but also some guy figures out let me
take this guy in his back yeah and the
guy is completely [ __ ] helpless yeah
and i've seen that in the ufc two or
three times and i've gone to myself
how can that guy
go into that high level of competition
and not at least be a purple belt you
gotta be well-rounded like an eight-nine
purple belt
each spot you gotta be able to draw hurt
people with your hands and then kill
people on the ground you know and that
when i got into comedy i improvised for
the first three years and i got nowhere
got you it was cute it wasn't like
no if it came
not at all i was up there talking [ __ ] i
would have two jokes go up there and go
mickey girls in the audience mickey gall
smacking [ __ ] you know in a way you
would leave then go i like joey yeah he
kind of pissed me off tonight because i
was and i picked up that habit in new
york
okay if you go to new york clubs during
the week they talk to a lot of audience
people yeah and some people are great at
it big j okay big monster at it you know
what i'm saying
but when you go do a show and people pay
25 bucks to go see you sometimes it
doesn't go over so well it doesn't go
over so well yeah
you're like that's why i started writing
comedy because the same reason if you
take me down on my back and i'm [ __ ]
helpless i can't even have guard you
you know i can't even have [ __ ] i
don't even know how to use my hips you
know little things that's how i can i
would watch fighters come up and go well
you know mickey goal wait till i fight
him he's never seen a right hand like
mine okay so you had three knockouts but
this is all you're counting on yeah i
want you to call somebody and go dog
listen i'm fighting diaz next time this
[ __ ] he thinks he's a good
wrestler i want you to teach me how to
take him down i'll do the rest
and every day for five [ __ ] weeks you
meet this guy at eight in the morning
and you take a dummy down where he
teaches you to well at least you learn
something in this camp yeah and even
when you fight me you're gonna go you
know what i may not be the master of
taking joey diaz down i'm gonna try it
one time i'm gonna try it high so you
can't guillotine me you know little
things yeah i want to see a fighter
evolve very fast hell yeah i always i
promise you every time you see me i'm
gonna be a new
so many new weapons like i've been
working really hard at my striking with
uh sean diggs
i'm i'm
i'm killing her right now i'm sharp like
i got i got a lot of new tricks i'm
excited to fight again so every time
you're never gonna get a read on me
every time i'm gonna be a completely
i'll whoop my ass who fought in my the
guy who fought in december i'll whoop
him now if i see him punk i'll whoop him
even worse you know it's funny how you
have eight limbs with
kickboxing you've got eight striking
points eight striking points you have
jujitsu you know you have all these
weapons to choose from yeah and if you
nobody says that you have to go and
learn
16 new sweeps and you just do you just
gotta practice one or two
little combo and let the guy today i got
that you know i'm really good at the
deep half
nice like i love the d-pad
you're always gonna pass my guard but
you're not gonna get your foot out of
these gorilla thighs okay i'm gonna hold
on to ever and i will pinch my [ __ ]
knees till i see your [ __ ] ankle turn
purple but i wanna pinching your ankles
yeah because i was going for the far leg
today alberto came up to me because i
said what are you doing for the coffee
that's the subaru one he goes let me
teach you the way i do it and he taught
me today and today i just said to myself
you know what i'm sick of being a [ __ ]
i'm gonna try it his way second guy i
sparred again his leg came up and i go
for this one i went for this one popped
him up grabbed onto it [ __ ] rolled
and crawled over
took a deep breath and just [ __ ] hit
back there you go and i love it i
[ __ ] loved it i don't i i went up to
him after class and he goes i saw what
you did he goes it was half good because
i called it i called when i can't do
something right it's a puerto rican way
yeah like today i couldn't do a bow and
arrow i can't my hand is too gorilla
yeah so i instead i go for an arm bar
okay why don't you do that i go i could
do it but i got to do a puerto rican bow
now
i got to just grab over here and do it
this way my hands and my wrists are
[ __ ] up yeah i try to work on my wrist
but you know it's the same thing you
want to try something new yeah every
time i go on stage i got to take a
chance
if i write something tonight
next time i go on stage i have three
things to say if i could use one of them
yeah i'm good same thing with whatever
you know what i've been working on my
knees he's a wrestler yeah i'm gonna try
to bait him and make him go for a thing
and i'm gonna pop my knee up yeah every
little weapon you could add but for
years i didn't see fighters do that and
sure enough it's like it's like
comedians just do the same jokes
you know what i mean yeah that's yeah
mma fighters that their their [ __ ] works
in the gym with the with gym guys who
you you know yeah that that works for
you there but your [ __ ] has to work on
the high level what are you doing you
gotta develop your kill [ __ ] and it's
gotta be get better and better and
better and better it's weird because
right now
i shot a special in october and i
probably got 10 new minutes i probably
got about 20 of scattered [ __ ]
that i really haven't really put focus
on but anywhere i'll go
i'll come up with something new you
gotta it's like the beatles when you're
gonna see the beatles you don't want to
hear that new [ __ ] nah you wanna hear
that i wanna hear hey hey hey so you
have like two classics you mix in there
you take one out you throw the new one
in
it's just been rough lately because i'm
trying to write any [ __ ] things at
once but i can't wait for those five
weeks i'm just going to do what i did
last year yeah go out four nights a week
to dumps with a tape recorder with my
man lee
and you get one [ __ ] gem a night yeah
just one gem of night yeah you know and
even if you go
yeah there you go it's like me taking
you to a smoker and i go just work the
jab tonight yeah it doesn't really
matter what happened nobody's here yeah
ain't nobody here just work that yes
like yeah accomplish something have to
take something yeah i always do that
people are going to do some same jokes
because they don't want to look bad yeah
that's on the way man that's like people
who don't who will just play a very safe
game because they don't want to tap out
in jiu jitsu you got to take chances and
find out in the gym what's right and
what's wrong if you or else you're gonna
need you're gonna someone's gonna have
to make that like in a fight make that
chaos for the sake of chaos and make an
opening
so you have to take chances in practice
too but you i'm sure you roll guys or
just stay really safe they they're too
egotistical and they just don't want to
let me tell you something wrong guys you
know what i mean that pull on me
when i clap your hand and you pull guard
on me i let you pull on me and pull on
me and pull on me my base
i'll let you pull on me for two hours
yeah and every two seconds i just pull
this little like that
i'm just oh you want you are one of
those all right oh yeah yeah but as a
white belt yeah you don't have a blue
belt but i'm no you're a blue i'm 54.
why you say you suck so bad you can't
suck that bad but
so what i try to do is i try to bait
this leg but the whole time i'm going
for this one yeah i'm going to put this
on my leg and i'm going to drop my hand
and pick your [ __ ] ass up and
pressure power you're playing a nice
heavy game yeah i like that
and then i watch yeah you got to do it
against gracie
what's up what's the guys from north
ridge bjj he's the heavyweight
like the baddest [ __ ] and and
like 220 or more oh
go to northwest
no northridge gracie baja
and then put put on first gracie watch
i'll tell you his name
northridge gracie baja and then we'll
put the video on that i learned jiu
jitsu from because for years if i wasn't
going to meet mickey gall i'm not going
back to jiu jitsu
but then i watched this animal against
roger gracie
this guy don't do this guy mounts you
and it's a slow death so what am i
searching for
no
what's the guy
northridge gracie baja right look at the
instructor's name okay gotcha
let's see here
we're just going to their website sorry
yeah that's what we were hoping you were
going for
the website my friends
i didn't know if you were waiting for
videos on youtube no no no no what's the
owner's name i'm looking right now and
he fought
who's the hodge gracie gracie yeah and
he's the kind of guy
that it takes a baral
see if you find romney though match
watch against gracie against roger
grayson i'm asking you it was it was a
game okay cool you got to see this yeah
first time i said what the [ __ ] am i
doing with my life i'm going in there
trying to be a [ __ ] break dancer yeah
i'm 54. these pros they don't [ __ ] do
much no it's just like let the other guy
make a mistake let him defeat something
yeah so i let them pull on me i'm pretty
sure right here
yeah
the whole time i got my hand on your
belt and i'm sticking my [ __ ] hand in
yeah so you can't breathe
so you can't breathe i don't want you to
breathe i can't breathe
i won't be able to breathe are you
coming with me and once i touch that leg
i need
slice a little bit and i switch real
quick and i got them in a four point was
it oh no and i'll sit there yeah and
i'll sit there until my ass grows roots
and again i'll let you huff and puff and
try to hip escape i'll go to [ __ ] one
o'clock yeah on my side control and i'll
hold on to your hips
that [ __ ] hip and your neck you're in
no danger look at it they didn't they
didn't these guys didn't karate chop
each other
this is a slow finger in the ass
speed it up my brother how far back
roger gracie versus romney romulo
a minute two minutes
yeah right there you just started right
from there
look at these guys they're not flying
through the [ __ ] air no
no it's high level [ __ ]
no that those are the fantasy i love
people who loved all the flying i can't
food bro if you go down to what's his
name simple [ __ ] works he's tremendous
that's one of my all-time favorites but
i can't do it
we were going to go to chrome
chrome gracie's oh well here yeah do you
uh what where's yours
mine is right down the corner
but cabrini is on welsh
uh kron is on culver city
yeah that's where that's right near
where bill lives i heard that's a great
[ __ ] place yeah i love uh
killers in there i'm an old man yeah you
got killers in there i need to [ __ ]
get [ __ ] up by blue belts and purple
belts that's it everybody else [ __ ] me
up but look at this this isn't look how
he grabs this [ __ ] thing everything's
very fundamental yeah they're not slight
adjustments yes
that barrel's not killing himself on the
bottom
you know this is the type of game
when i watch this i go oh i get it now
i'm not supposed to be tarzan no i'm 50
[ __ ] four you got to wait for either
mickey
to make a move and then i'll make a
little inch yeah
and that's how you learned each other
and but this
this
also helps me with comedy
you follow me this style
give him a slow burn
yeah this style of jiu-jitsu is what
works
for a fat [ __ ] like me
look at the guy in the bottom he ain't
even breathing heavy he does this every
day for breakfast yeah
yeah this is the [ __ ] i watched look at
now we got a little
yeah boom
boom
yeah this is beautiful [ __ ] yeah i'm
glad you turned me on to this
this is the [ __ ] i watch when i get high
at night and i come all over myself
i wish i started this game at 20. [ __ ] i
wish i could do something like this in
the competition even as a blue ball i
wish i could do that i gave you do you
plan on competing ever no
we have some stuff prepare for you when
you come back to jersey some jiu jitsu
man you're like yo give me some fat man
jiu jitsu okay we have it ready for you
five minute jiu jitsu fat man jiu jitsu
that's what you called it we'll do some
we'll do some half guard [ __ ]
cuz i'm getting up from the bottom i'm
having a hard time tell me what you yeah
i'm having a hard time pulling the guy
into my guard especially into like make
him believe i'm going to pull him into
my guard but then i chop my leg across
okay and i got a half guard and i start
working the deep half right from the guy
i get the underhook high and i start
working the deep half
and i just that's your go-to
that's all i got right there and i got a
camaro from the top and then a cuban
north south choke it's not the way you
guys do it i have to put my hand under
his neck
and twist and keep my arm because i
can't do the and i'm not getting bad i'm
i'm getting better with jeffy one oh
he's
yeah you know i don't have much to offer
but look at these guys you see these
guys flying through here he's like sniff
my ass if you want to
sniff that muffler if you want to
that's that that's a hixson style man
that pressure
yeah he does this for [ __ ] 18 minutes
guys i was concerned do these matches
have no time limit no 15 minutes i think
but to do this for 15 minutes i'd have
10 heart attacks
i'm going to take 10 baby aspirins
i would love to go to romelu brown
school but i would [ __ ] my pants just
walk into the door
it's a big guy school i heard it's a big
guy's school but they're
240 shredded big you know what i'm
saying those type of gorillas i can't
deal with that they'll give me your
[ __ ] kill
yeah
look at this the position has it's just
such slight alterations like i bet
someone doesn't do jiu-jitsu couldn't
really notice the differences of what's
happening i don't even know what the
[ __ ] really going on i'm just playing
it by here but i see how he's grabbing
his collar he's trying to just stack
yeah he's saying
but he's just chilling on the bottom
you're saying real relaxed
really amazing stuff this is how i got
into it this is why i wanted to give it
a try i would watch eddie's tapes and
then i would watch marcelo garcia and
every time i met somebody i would go
home and look him up on youtube after
i'd see him in a fight yeah and i'd
become a man i could never do this [ __ ]
i never even wrestled in high school
i'm not trying to uh
speak badly about this
but after seeing some of ebi it's
amazing to see the difference and to see
how entertaining even like there is a
difference between this and what ebi is
now yeah it's a bit it's a it's it's
more of a chess game a little bit rather
than an athletic
an ebi moves oh it's great it's that new
that nogi too yeah no and it's just a
mission so people are playing legs all
the time yeah no no that [ __ ] moves too
quick i don't even know what the [ __ ]
they're doing they're going for their
feet and [ __ ] you know what i don't like
people going from like i do stand up
comedy
[Music]
yeah that's like [ __ ] iranian spit
that'll stick on you you can't [ __ ]
get that off of the waters there goes
our iranian fans all right you could
turn this up before we get you know i
got a i got a funny story yeah i was
telling the other day um to bert he
liked it
so when i was in we were in denver like
for the ufc fights in january with the
cerrone thoughts
all right the last night we were there i
got in a bar fight
i haven't been in one since like college
and it was like i don't you know i don't
i don't do like i'm not out there
looking for children
i was uh so i go to this i go to this
bar with dan henderson
uh pat berry and rosenham and junis and
like dustin jacoby like a bunch of
badasses and we were downstairs and i i
was drinking a little bit but and people
are just standing around and you're like
excuse me excuse me trying to walk so i
guess i i was a little drunk so i
probably pushed through a little bit and
i went to turn around
to be like oh my god my bad and the two
guys are squared up with me
two guys squared up like i turn around
and they're both in like fighting stands
like i was like oh [ __ ] it's about to
happen
so
i hit the one guy
and then i find out the next day the
other guy must have cracked me in the
head because i felt like the bump i
didn't feel it or anything there
so i dropped the one guy and then i'm
next thing i know i'm on top of the
other guy and he's kind of holding me in
a guillotine and i'm like yo no one in
the world
is going to get to me especially not
this [ __ ] and this denver bar
right so i'm waiting i'm like about to
burst down i'm like oh i'm gonna get
this kid in a second i'm gonna start
dropping elbows on him security grabs me
like mickey mickey stop making stop so i
was immediately like embarrassed like
damn they knew who i they know who i am
i'm like damn i'm gonna see this on uh
like on twitter or something tomorrow
so then and then security's like yo you
gotta go you're on top of them you gotta
leave so
next morning i get a text so we end up
going going back catching an uber uh
next morning i get a text from pat berry
he's like yo are you all right
everything good i was like oh he must
have seen me you know like scuffling and
got
get out of there he's like the guy who
shot up the club was right in front of
our van
so i didn't even know about this because
we got out of there
maybe it was a blessing in disguise
because after i got kicked out of the
club someone shot that place up
oh my god i'm crazy
and then and then we're actually when
we're standing outside these these like
four like these four kids come up and me
and him are kind of just standing there
we're a little drunk we're a little mad
where was this bar uh i don't know it's
in denver
but then we're standing outside and
these kids come up to us and they start
looking at us and we're and they're like
yo we're with our dads if you hurt our
dads we're gonna kill you we're just
standing there like standing on the side
like what like just standing there they
said they're like start getting
aggressive with us so me and him we're
like
start taking our jackets off like come
here i'm smacking that
hey we started they didn't do it they
did they walked on but like we're just
standing there they started like talking
[ __ ] to us bill he's all mushmouth he's
all drunk south jersey wild bills coming
out he started taking his jacket off
like yeah
[ __ ] wild people now let me ask you
this do people pick fights for you
not really i i mean
i remember the last fight i got into in
rutgers i think i
i was i was standing in a bar and i
started feeling a poke at like my lower
back there's a crowded bar i'm like
someone's you know people are just
swaying you know the bars move and then
i feel really feel real pushed so i turn
around and there's this kid just
standing there glaring at me like yo
he's drunk and [ __ ] he's like yeah i'ma
[ __ ] you up
and i was like what
like what i don't i've never met you
he's just standing behind me but i'm
like what'd you say he's like yo i'm
gonna [ __ ] you up he's like i was like
all right you wanna go outside he's like
yeah and as i start to step like to walk
out he starts to like square up and i
drop an elbow right on him i elbowed
this kid in his face so [ __ ] hard he
went down he was and then my friends who
were bouncing the ball like mickey come
outside come outside real quick so then
10 minutes later ten minutes later
they're taking this kid out with bloody
mouth uh over over two people's
shoulders
now those were the last two fights again
i don't go out there looking for fuzz
i'd get my fights in the gym i'm not
trying to you know i mean you know it
should happen sometimes you gotta no i
can't like
to me or you it's going to be you i
could see you going like a wild crazy
jersey bar
and you know as soon as you go yeah that
was rutgers you know
crazy [ __ ] a guy like you walks
into a bar and it spreads like wildfire
yeah and there's always that one guy
that's like [ __ ] him yeah in front of
his three little [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] him i was a purple belt in
jiu jitsu
or one of those guys that beat you in a
contest early like when you were a blue
bell he got away with an arm bar or some
[ __ ] nah
they'll come over and try to
i always thought that this once a month
at least you run into somebody who's
coming hey man
you're a ufc man let me tell you
something i eat ufc dudes for breakfast
you know yeah
i got a lot of heart if they let me in
there man you know it's like oh okay yo
i hate watching with i hate watching
fights with like for lack of a better
word like civilians they'll be like dude
why is he not just elbowing him if i was
in there i [ __ ] hit him with the
elbow and then i punch him and then i
you know
my dad will do that sometimes i'm like
yo dad come on no you're professional
for a reason yeah he's a chiropractor no
[ __ ] george chiropractic in new jersey
damn green brook and he does all the
[ __ ] electrodes yeah puts that [ __ ]
cracks me up keeps me especially getting
our next pulled on in jiu jitsu
keeps me well i went the other day i
went on tuesday yeah
i go to this place
back for something
it's a great deal what they give me and
i stick with it you know i try to go for
you i go for pilates and an adjustment
yeah sometimes i go for massage and an
adjustment a massage are great
during fight camp i do that like two
times a year you have to i don't go
every week i'm not johnny lamore i do it
twice a week i do i spend 240 bucks of a
week on the whole
but yeah but it helps me keeps me on the
mat lets me train hard as heck she told
me that if i kept my insurance she would
charge me the same if i wouldn't charge
my insurance i said done
and it's [ __ ] cheap i was like [ __ ]
it
so i either take like i didn't go for
three weeks you know i was on the road
and [ __ ] which after you fly you should
go see a chiropractor the next [ __ ]
day yeah they adjust you and open up
your [ __ ] i like that i'm an acupuncture
guy 11 years
with the same acupuncture shake yeah
i've already talked about it before
i never had that before yeah you got to
have that you got chinatown close to
your house that's a train ride a half a
doob yeah you're going to chinatown
there's some crazy chinese guy who'll
give you some herbs and [ __ ] yeah yeah
shoot you get some needles yeah
and you know what man the more you take
care of yourself the better off you are
later on yes yeah i i truly believe that
that
how you look you know when we when i was
growing up if you were over 50 you just
didn't work out
you just didn't work out it was your
bodies are certain yeah no now we live
in a different civilization where
people are [ __ ] out there you know
look at this lady from the boston
marathon you read that that in 19
whatever they would she was the first
lady to run the boston marathon
and they showed a picture her
the men ripping her number off her and
pushing every [ __ ]
they you know they tried to yeah the guy
was trying to push her off yeah the guy
in the suit was trying to push her off
the track she just ran the boston
marathon 70 years old
and came in 25 percentile
you know what that does for you like you
have to sit there and go you know what
i'm going to try and i'll tell you it's
got to be hell on her body dude if you
could if you could run 26.2 miles that's
what the boston marathon is that's yeah
that's what a marathon is
25th percentile is great but just doing
it in any percentile
is amazing i can't imagine like just to
run the 26 miles yeah absolutely right
they have people uh in wheelchairs doing
it i couldn't [ __ ] tricycle 26 months
you know what i'm saying like reef it up
and [ __ ] bicycles it's not like a
track like did you ever have like uh
like like a track when in like a
football when you're wearing laps they
have like this thing called heartbreak
hill it's it sounds like a north bergen
hill
and and it's it's it's
i can't imagine doing it it's crazy like
running up that [ __ ] hill i'd like
the 11th mile i don't know
any road work i do especially especially
in camp i i do uh i do like a treadmill
i'll do
uh a five minute round but constantly
increasing the speed so boo boo boo boo
increase the speed
increase the incline so i'm finishing my
round strong by the end i'm sprinting
sprinting straight uphill the
treadmill's jacked to the end then i get
off i'll rest a minute
and i'll just stand outside
breathe catch my breath and then i set
the treadmill back down to like a like
five six and then once i start every you
know 15 30 seconds
harder so i'm conditioned myself to
finish strong finish even faster than i
start no rocky running on the streets a
little bit kids chasing
a little bit you got potholes and [ __ ]
man can't twist an ankle you can't
afford
mickey where you going we got a nice
sausage and peppers yeah yeah
yeah good i'll go down to green brook
middle school around the track a little
bit
yeah
you got to be careful i see that i got
it yeah smooth [ __ ] i've ran in grass
because it's like nice and soft and i've
busted my ass fall fall on my face look
like an idiot and you could yeah that's
not as bad as if i were to like [ __ ] up
my ankle you know i think the most i
ever ran when i got out of the halfway
house i got into running and swimming
yeah i became like a master swimming
program and she would encourage me to
run
so i got the sneakers i got the whole
[ __ ] thing
and i would run boulder creek but it was
concrete man
i could feel it you know when i got
precise it's not good for you yeah it's
not good for your knees yeah and i was
like then it wasn't stuff don't run on
concrete who the [ __ ] knows when you're
29. they can tell you don't run out of
better nails that's the first [ __ ]
thing you're going to do is run on the
better nails you know you think you're
invincible yeah and i got that fascist
pilates with your [ __ ] heel they
gotta plantar fasciitis that's they
don't want they gotta furiously they
gotta shoot a thing of cortisone into
the bubble
yeah oh i turned green the first time no
[ __ ] bueno i got the orthotics still
i got these other orthotics and these
new whatever what do you call them
newbie nb
new balance loop balance okay which are
[ __ ] tremendous
that's working good for you my pops has
got that he went to the chiropractor
recently got a few things crap yeah no
no tremendous oh my gosh
you go to [ __ ]
the whatever store
and they have a really great one they
measure you you put your weight
the guy was from new york in columbus
ohio he had a warrant in the bronx
so he moved to columbus he was going to
get out of there he was selling shoes on
the cover with an alias he came from
hello he's going to move now
for a while he came to my comedy show
that night he broke it down man the wife
didn't want me to come
i got warrants in new york i stabbed the
dude
i changed my name i'm over here selling
sneakers like a [ __ ] mook
but he was a good dude he was a good
dude he was a good dude
oh my goodness
so that's it and that's that
so mickey um sir
how does a uh an up-and-coming fighter
like you survive
in between fights financially like was
it how like sponsorships work if you're
if you're
if you're lucky enough you can make some
money on sponsorships you know some
people you get like a monthly stipend or
you do different things to make you know
make appearances here there like the
other week i went to a bar me and jim
miller we like did like meet and greets
made some money
um
you know you get you get the chunk of
your ch of your
earnings is it fights if you so if
you're not fighting you're not making
money and even then i i'm
blanking on the names right now
even the main card some of the fighters
on on the last fox card got like
eight to show
like eight thousand yeah that's low oh
yeah but that that yeah it just seemed
like
and then i don't know i didn't i didn't
do the research but it some people had a
uh to show and a win bonus and it looked
like demetrius just had like a show flat
a flat so some people do that some
people have certain things with it
worked out especially like more veteran
guys it's like it'll be like a flat rate
win or lose they're making like
demetrius what do you make five hundred
thousand i think when they listen to
four or something okay yeah something
like that
yeah
yeah it's uh
it's a tough racket man you live with
your parents nah i'm not anymore now
yeah and there's yeah and they're split
now
that's why i remember no that's all good
they've been split it's all old news um
uh yeah i have the two baby sisters
remember we talked about before the
two-year-old four-year-old they're 20
and 22 years younger than me yeah yeah
yeah yeah they're awesome look here
you have your own family yeah yeah we're
getting our spot out in out in lebanon
no he's out in culver city out here oh
we're we're figuring something out while
building trying to focus
bill i well i was home in jersey doing a
bunch of filming so i was at gracie for
a while
yeah in my school i went to crohn's a
couple times
you get you got you got him back into it
like he was getting soft out here man
and then you when you gave him i don't
know if you even remember yeah yeah and
you you gave him the speech and he you
know he's like yeah i'm i'm i'm
motivated right and now he's been back
you guys
training with the killers man he's doing
my practices some days yeah you got that
shame
oh that's the great when you go up to
somebody and go [ __ ] me up i love
telling brown but just [ __ ] me up yeah
do it quickly
and sometimes you last you know you get
a sleeve it's good for you man you're
always learning some brown belt yolked
me today yeah but i crawl under him i
did some [ __ ] and then he got me with
the choke but at least i lasted to the
bell rang yeah so for me you know what i
lasted usually i had to tap out because
i was tired i protected myself that kept
him that's what it is
good
you know i i caught his arm when you're
especially when you're training with
someone better more experienced than you
don't give them [ __ ] should be like you
know what i mean like like take take a
little chance but then you know don't
everything you earn make them take it
away take your time like if you've got a
good position chill on it hold it you
know what i mean
no once i pass a guard i got to hold it
for two minutes good take it breathe
just
oh yeah take deep breaths on my tippy
toes
breathe in their
ears
i know all those dirty threats yeah yeah
yeah you know you take away their oxygen
you know 300 pounds on your stomach yeah
is [ __ ] rough yeah you know i don't
neon belly people okay because that
could hurt something see i learned neon
belly for me yeah you'd have to be easy
and i've done it a couple times and i've
heard people going
so i'm like
no
you guys didn't know you could do that
though if you ever yeah no no no no if i
pull your sleeve if i grab the collar
and get that neon belly and get that
foot
sideways i'll pop your [ __ ] rib by
mistake and you're my goomba i don't
want to do that to you yeah yeah the
last thing i saw i don't need belly
nobody sometimes i'll tell you i go
listen i'm going to transition to neon
belly
i'm just gonna do it real fast let me
just see how if i could do the movement
to drill it like keep your toes on the
ground yeah
jesus joey that neon belly is the real
deal
you gotta do something with your [ __ ]
time man now i'm happy that everything's
you're waiting for a fight there's going
to be a bunch of cards this [ __ ]
summer yeah
so you have some fun
[ __ ] yeah i'm gonna hurt some people
well so after dallas what do they got
after dallas you got to have the
memorial 211 yeah 211 no 5 uh 12.
may 12th yeah no 211 those the car okay
i believe or 2012 i can't remember man
and then you have the end of may
and then you're gonna have the fourth of
july there's a may 13th there's a card
the big one in dallas yes that's the one
yes right
um yeah man there's there's car that's
the ufc right now there's not a lack of
talent
talent um cards like you you turn on and
like there was one last weekend there's
the one the weekend before
there's one this weekend
you know there's one last weekend uh the
main event is artem lobov versus cub
swanson okay that's right that's right
there's some nice yeah there's some
there's some good fights on there some
fun fights
last week's was fun
week before you had dc rumble
i went to buffalo i didn't stay for the
fight really yeah i just did the show
and came back yo that weiman [ __ ] was
crazy you saw that i saw it
uh
[ __ ] happens
you know there yeah the referee made a
mistake yes
um
i love merkley altitude wydon said
something in that corner that made that
doctor
they asked him what mother was he said
february february apparently right so
yeah if you say february you've been
training for it's on your [ __ ] couch
you know you know it when you fight
something something wasn't right yeah
you know
i feel bad for weidman you know i do
after even
you don't want to win like that no i
think wyden will come back stronger for
sure um you know things this is
listen it's not uh
it's longevity
and comedy and this you know it's like
it's not a strange i always [ __ ] say
this
i did not know until recently
that the average
time a running back last in the nfl is
three years
you have three years
that's the that's the [ __ ] take a
beating that's a three-year beating that
you could either you get hurt you're
done you pull a hamstring you [ __ ] up a
knee
then that's it you know it's really
tough to come back from that for you you
know like a good need [ __ ] accident
acl eight month a year recovery you're
not coming back dog by that time they
got three new [ __ ] rookies in your
slot that are faster and meaner than you
are just the way reality is you know
yeah but with the ufc you got to figure
out what the longevity is
how long you want to do it
what you want to attain from it and how
long do you want to do it you know right
now dude i'm just obsessed like the
little this little six bit of success
i've had the past year has made me like
a lot a lot hungrier it's made me you
know just i can't get enough i can't get
enough of the gym i'm having fun i
seeing my [ __ ] just get sharper and
sharper it's it's fun for me i'm very
passionate about that right that's all i
want to do is fight when fights beat
people up i mean
you should be so excited about the
future because
you're 10 years away from your product
yeah i don't know i know
i know what you're going to learn in 10
years and how much mma is going to
evolve yeah it's going to blow
everybody's everybody's wig off at this
table you know mma is going to evolve
you're going to evolve yeah i'm excited
to see what happens you know we're
flying sidekicks
yeah come into the game dude yeah
there's always a new evolution you know
it's always a new evolution you know and
people are going to be training
differently and pretty soon people are
going to be doing jiu jitsu on the water
with gas masks on yeah because you know
you never [ __ ] know you know
every month somebody i love those i love
those
i love those ufc countdowns and there's
always one new strength and conditioning
guy yeah on every episode this we turn
to this guy now for his assistance he's
worked with former green bay packers
he's got your hammer in and jumping up
and down backwards then you go in there
and get knocked out
you know what i'm saying like it's
always
i like the guys that are with the same
people yeah
yeah i like the guys that when they do
get knocked out three times
they don't go to a downtown
you can't go to a different camp it's
something you're doing you're not
listening to your corner
you know these are the things that are
ego gets in the way like sure you know
that's why i've never really given a
[ __ ] about ego
there's always room for improvement
people always want to criticize you yeah
you're not gonna they're always gonna
think they know better tell you what you
did right i'm not gonna make everybody
happy you're never gonna please
everybody okay you could fight 10 fights
knock everybody out in the first round
and there's always going to be that
rider yeah that's going to throw a doubt
in there well he's never been pushed to
the second round [ __ ] because i knock
everybody out in the first round yeah i
love you know i told rogan a couple
weeks ago
how one of the main reasons i got into
jiu jitsu was because yeah i studied
karate as a kid and i went to
competitions and [ __ ]
but i wanted to know what you guys went
through in a way
like i wanted to not so i knew what i
was telling you how many [ __ ]
december 31 cards i've been to
bunch and that's the different audience
that's the real those are the people
that drink starbucks they go to december
31st
okay they're there because it's cute yes
that's why you can't have a brazilian on
the main card yeah you got to have two
white people on the main card for
[ __ ] the new year's card
because it's completely different they
go to fights for different ways and i've
told joe because joe's usually
announcing them but i'm in the audience
that's the only card that they won't
give us seats behind joe
the seats are so expensive that they
give us they want that money in the
first whatever which is still great
seats i'm very fortunate to get out i'm
not complaining but we would sit behind
couples
like four people two of them both had
fake tits
the two husbands both had designer jeans
designer haircuts designer shirts but
the one guy was a blue belt
oh [ __ ] okay how do you know because he
would say it well you hear him talking
like being like he's the master yeah
like he's the man right now he's gonna
get him in a camora i got my training
partner nakamura one time and the girls
would be oh my
god he does jiu jitsu he's so excited
and the one guy will be bill you're such
a badass
you know
savage oh my god you're such a badass
you train with these guys well not
really those guys but guys just like
yeah my instructor was in the olympics
he was you know and you listen to these
jerk offs i do ufc yeah so i didn't
wanna you know like i said this a
thousand times nothing bothers me
when a sports writer of any kind
criticizes a professional athlete with
like a knock
if you are not hitting home runs you're
not hitting home runs
but if you're hitting 56 home runs
there's that one sports ride would
always go well
he he's a terrible single hitter yeah or
he's number two in strikeouts [ __ ] he's
got 64 home runs to hit 64 home runs you
got to strike out a couple times you're
going for deep [ __ ] bombs you know
what i'm saying
people always find that one [ __ ]
knock and it drives me crazy i see it on
facebook all the time when a new special
gets released
somebody always has a knock on somebody
in there i watched the amy schumer thing
shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up what the [ __ ] do you
know what we go through yeah you know
what i'm saying what the [ __ ] do you
know what happens to somebody like amy
schumer when you have 22 offers in your
head and you're trying to write a joke
you know it's a complete different game
that's what happens with champions you
know next thing you know you're doing 22
[ __ ] interviews a week you're
training you got six chicks sucking your
dick you're eating spaghetti instead of
the canola what's that [ __ ] they make
quinoa quinoa
you're eating spaghetti with meatballs
instead of quinoa kino whatever the [ __ ]
it is
so
and then you wonder why you got nothing
i like it that way better yeah then you
wonder why you got knocked out yeah
because your obligations go somewhere
else now you got to be focused it's
tough for me to do a thousand things and
really really really sit down
and write what's in my heart
and you can fake the funk i like when
these fighters
go back to doing this well i'm going
back to my old prank you know i got
knocked out six times in a row i'm gonna
go through my first coach now you know
that right there shows your
indecisiveness to weak and i've seen it
with comics they lose the show they fire
everybody
i'm right in my head i go that guy's
done
because he's not accepting the blame
he's blaming on the people around him
yeah it's like an excuse there's only
one [ __ ] fighter that could
blame the manager and that's ronda
rousey's manager
she's the only one that can really go
you know what you really [ __ ] suck
i think he's the only one that all the
sports writers could really i listened
to his audio from the last fight i'm
talking about edmond
ronda rousey i'm very embarrassed for
him
and he might be a nice guy you know i
don't know what he's like in his real
life
but i felt really embarrassed for him
after that did you ever hear that i did
yeah no
i didn't no
you ever hear it no no no
i heard it it was something shocking
like can you find it lee on youtube or
something
how do you
spell his last name ronda rousey
oh yeah yeah edward
[ __ ] uh t-a-r-t-a-r
there we go terrarian
ronda rousey it'll say it right on there
yeah i put like audi yeah there you go
begging wasn't one brother is he to move
her head yeah yeah that's it okay
it's [ __ ] terrible
you know this is a coach shouting
instruction for the people listening
during a fight during the fight against
amanda nunes right yeah
[Applause]
yes move
[Applause]
there we go
head down head up hands up
catcher
straight
head movement good job
she's getting punched in the head a
thousand times you can hear it in his
voice yeah please
[Applause]
[Music]
what percentage do coaches get
no i don't
know
and she's being murdered
[Applause]
that's really [ __ ] sad it probably
felt like an eternity to him i know i've
i've i've been to the hospital three
times in the past year for my training
part guys who i've been in the corner
for
it's it's it's like it's like a shocking
thing to see i've seen a couple my
buddies that get knocked out and that
that shit's like that's the best of my
boys i blow up so in tears with these
guys then you watch their dreams get
crushed and their body gets shut off
it's wild man
i was there for gsp
john fitch yeah and i'll never forget
standing there
and seeing john fitch get taken into a
[ __ ] ambulance
i wanted to cry for him you know he
fought
gsp like a [ __ ] soldier
but he was he needed stitches and [ __ ] i
can't imagine you break my nose i'm done
fighting oh my god
i'm done
oh you just broke mickey up you break
mickey's nose you just woke me up now
you can't breathe
i tap out listen i can't breathe my nose
is crooked it looks like call me his
nose
i'm done i'm not doing this these guys
come out with a broken nose
[ __ ] up eye sockets the taste of blood
in your mouth if i gotta fight you
that's my super superpower is coming out
now oh my god
what's more the most painful but you
mean like like a leg like one of those
leg kicks like a punch to the face like
an elbow like what's the most
pain or the throat that's all gone to
adrenaline
i mean yeah in the fight i haven't felt
pain really wow but in practice i mean
i'll tell the worst stuff is like if you
get like like you get like a glove in
the eye
getting poke noggin kicking the nuts i
mean [ __ ] that's illegal that stuff
hurts
um
leg kicks if you condition your leg
right you should they shouldn't hurt too
bad i'll tell you what looks like it
hurts i needed a head from yo romero
yeah yeah yeah that shit's gonna [ __ ]
hurt
a [ __ ] i don't ever want i'll i don't i
don't need to ever know that a [ __ ]
liver kick from [ __ ]
black dude no all bob boza what's the
big black guy the liver kick brock
lesnar uh alistair over alistar overeem
like one of those liver kicks you don't
ever want to feel that [ __ ] you know i
remember getting in karate one time in
the tournament getting the air knocked
out of me
it was one of the worst feelings i've
ever [ __ ] experienced in my life i
thought i was gonna die i was just a
young kid i've been there kicked me in
the [ __ ] stomach with everything he
had he got disqualified and i won yeah
but jesus christ i started crying i
couldn't [ __ ] breathe
i'm not cut out for that [ __ ] get hit in
the head with bottles and [ __ ] that was
never my bag that's a different type of
jersey breed there's a certain jersey
breed that's in a buddy of mine
vinnie lynch got rested so i seen him in
philadelphia he got hit in the head with
like a [ __ ] johnny walker black
bottle and he didn't even flinch he
didn't even [ __ ] flinch blood was
pouring out of his head he didn't know
that [ __ ] has always freaked me the [ __ ]
out this guy's you could stab him and
then
i had a friend in high school george mum
from jersey city
i saw him the night we were supposed to
graduate like he never he was one of
those kids that would only go to school
during football season yeah jersey has
those guys
they just talking about they just come
to school during football season and
dude coming to play ball and once
football season ends they drop out
and then they come back to next year to
do nothing to live white and drink beer
georgie mum was at dickinson high school
and he transferred to north bergen
and he wouldn't go to practice and one
day the coaches went to his house
and he told the coaches listen i don't
know if you know this i don't practice
and they're like what are you talking
about come again
like i don't practice
just put me in a [ __ ] cage
come here and let me out on saturdays
the coaches didn't know what to do but
that's what he did he come in on
saturday and just kill people on the
field well i'll tell you what the last
time i saw georgie mum
he got hit by a car in jersey city and
he flew off a cliff
he's out with the stitches
in his head he took the bandage off and
he had a ghetto blaster and it was like
nothing had happened
he had gotten like 30 stitches on the
side of his head
and you thought nothing had happened in
his life
i i always tend to look for georgie mom
on facebook there's not a georgia
facebook now
there's people that are just [ __ ]
tough man that you could hit in the head
that was not my game i don't know
i don't mind getting punched in the face
that's okay that wakes you up a little
bit yeah but once you loosen one of my
teeth or you [ __ ] up my nose that's a
different territory or you submit me and
is this a mission where your ass is in
my face
yeah i'll [ __ ] you up later
i'm getting you back [ __ ] you up my
revenge is coming i'll clap i'll give
you a hug
karate hottie got beat up the other day
she's giving hugs this [ __ ] that was a
great fight i don't trust the karate
holly that chick is at home doing
chinese voodoo
right now those chinese people you [ __ ]
with them they're making a comeback
that's why i don't eat vietnamese food
we bombed them for 10 years you think
they're gonna [ __ ] make you a good
dinner they're planning their revenge
little by little they put cancer so far
they put little cats
yeah you think japan is doing the same
with that sushi they give us radioactive
we blew them [ __ ] island up didn't we
we [ __ ] them up you think they're just
going to forget about that [ __ ] there's
japanese people with four eyes you think
they're going to [ __ ]
you think they're going to [ __ ]
forget about [ __ ] that happen no
no
everybody hey the [ __ ] always comes
back dog so that's why you got to be
careful huh
who's the [ __ ] that that's the car
mission the [ __ ]
always comes back
oh my god oh man listen i'm going to be
excited
when they give you a [ __ ] fight here
you're over there i'm gonna break this
whoever's next break them up good
do you have uh
anyone you want to call out nah man
everybody everybody 70s everybody
everybody everyone can get something
everybody's everyone gets them i got
enough forever even demetrius johnson
put them on his little ass off
to 126. squash
how good is that [ __ ] dude yeah he's
the best he's a pound for pound yeah
he's he's he does everything perfect i
like his coach
i really like his coach matt hume if i
was a fighter there'd be a couple people
i trained with who
if i was a fighter i gotta say for us
i like garage
great mod for us has a great mind and
he's a great strategist
did great work with gsp just phenomenal
work with gsb uh-huh
um
i respect the guys that at t my good
buddy att yeah i'll be down there every
month
oh yeah north korea the best [ __ ]
wrestlers that's my man yeah you know i
love george mazdaval i think that place
had too much testosterone
i love duke rufus i think duke rufus is
a great coach yeah i think his gym
doesn't have enough
like he's you know what i'm saying more
to pettis
it's customized around people okay you
know yeah i think he's a great
kickboxing coach you know i love the
guys in new mexico
yeah i love walmart
jackson winkle john i would train to be
honest i would train in denver year
round
yeah and do more
yeah dwayne bang
you have that elevation
yeah world-class jiu-jitsu
plus your cardio would be to a different
level yeah and living close to boulder
you're probably going to be around the
best people for your body that you could
be around what does that mean
boulder colorado is a [ __ ] healing
okay community it's a happy community
that now it's very high level and stuff
but that essence good people good energy
yeah you know that essence is still in
boulder when i lived in boulder how did
i find out about my feet
if you go to the harvest restaurant
which is a vegetarian restaurant they
had a sign that said um
mondays a doctor comes in from six to
nine and does free
feed exam if you feed her that's how i
found that he gave me a new pair of
sneakers he coached me whatever after
that he goes you know i'll get you with
a coach to teach how to run properly
the boulder is made for that when people
really want to excel
in health and fitness a lot of those
people go to boulder they're really good
you know
it's a really interesting place i would
live there i would go down to the
colorado olympic training facility yeah
okay but i would always switch up my
altitude
yeah i would i felt it out there yeah i
would always switch up my altitude i
would go to denver and do bonkins for
six weeks
and really stretch your lungs out really
live up there really
what's that called when your body
acclimates acclimates you know and you
have to sleep a lot because you build
more red blood cells you build more
cells
so when you move to like let's say you
went to aspen
the first three weeks you're gonna see
you're gonna be sucking wind oh you're
gonna be tired yeah you really don't
want to work out you're just gonna go
for a walk yeah that we we were like
we're like [ __ ] around like climbing
the steps of the hotel
are there fighters who will say like no
i don't want to fight in an elevation
maybe later
if i'm gonna fight in elevation for yeah
if i wanna find elevation i'm gonna need
to go somewhere fight so like emerge
myself submerge myself in that elevation
you know what i mean because or else
it's gonna be a shock look at what
[ __ ] kane fought for doom doom was
down there for eight months before that
drinking water
was [ __ ] acclimating yeah and and uh
kane didn't think about his team didn't
want to go down there but two weeks
before yeah two weeks now i'm not gonna
do it i'm surprised very surprised
george mazdaval did it on six weeks and
five weeks he's a thug man he really
didn't love him yeah he did it on five
weeks
the acclimation process i remember being
19
and moving to aspen in the first two
weeks it was basically getting up to eat
watch tv for an hour and before you know
it and you [ __ ] pass it out your body
has to build those cells
to breathe but after two or three months
then you start running in it
like the first time i did a bomb hit and
asked when i passed out
passed out my friends were like don't do
that bunker i'm like what what are you
[ __ ] kidding me i'm johnny bananas
next thing you know i woke up the bong
was broken and i was sideways or the
fire escape
that's the yeah that's how big of a and
then they have altitude sickness
where if i take you up in the mountain
and keep you up there for a long time
and give you booze and marijuana oh lord
you're gonna get [ __ ] up and sick
really you're gonna get sick like that's
why i don't like ski vacations
because you're going somewhere for three
days that's [ __ ] you up
especially if you get up higher you need
a day just to walk around
just to walk around sleep you can't eat
a full meal because you need every inch
of your [ __ ] lungs
you don't want to eat a full meal you
need every [ __ ] inch of your lungs
[ __ ]
those babies working but that's just me
what's working no the yeah your lungs
what's up well uh uh if i camp as hard
enough as it is as it is to do like two
days and then do it in a place where it
feels like you're like breathing through
a straw it's rough
yeah i don't think i would take you
directly and start two a days
no you gotta i would take you for two
man the word is acclimated you gotta and
then another two weeks a little jog
jiu jitsu real light with a ghee yeah
you know maybe something into it yeah
yeah you got to ease into it drink a lot
of fluids maybe an iv from time to time
drain some blood get some new blood
cooking and [ __ ] you know take six
ounces out of blood maybe 16 ounces get
that blood rebuilding that's good listen
giving blood is great for you i don't do
it enough if i didn't let if i wasn't
scared of needles i would change my
blood once a month like keith richards
i would go to [ __ ] in that place and
give him 16 ounces of blood
every month by the end of the year you
give them [ __ ]
190 [ __ ] ounces of blood you like
dracula you got all new blood in you
that your body made every year you live
forever it just makes sense
that's my opinion i'm not a [ __ ]
doctor i just smoke weed
and have a good like a doctor like a
doctor let's wrap this up don't forget
you [ __ ]
420
oxnard levity live 8pm show friday night
7 4 30
9 45
saturday night seven o'clock
9 30.
get a hold of oxnard go to improv.com
click on
and get your [ __ ] tickets and come up
there leo be up there tomorrow night
with his dad
we got the nurse coming we're shooting
heroin from [ __ ] bulgaria
and that's just the way it is how are
you feeling dick syed is the acid
hitting you yet
have we
we just gave you a little taste no i'm
doing great very happy i was trying to
start it before but i [ __ ] it up i
read the wrong information so i'm very
sorry as you know blue apron is one of
our sponsors blue apron is the number
one
fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service
in the country lee's tried blue apron
i've had bellope and lee's dad's had it
we're all very happy with blue apron all
right they've established partnerships
with 150 local farms fisheries
and rancheries and ranchers across the
united states all right
you know cooking together builds strong
family bonds
research shows that blue apron families
cook nearly three times more often those
who spend a lot at restaurants or at
high-end grocery chain can now spend
under ten dollars a person
for a delicious meal okay let me talk to
you about the upcoming meals here you
got fresh wonton noodles with cabbage
and carrots you got spicy tomato
with uh uh oil spicy tomato and olive
pasta with ricotta cheese who's better
than you you got cajun chicken
sandwiches with arugula salad you got
paprika spiced salmon you got shiitake
and red cabbage fried rice with a sunny
side up egg are you kidding me eating
good or what you're eating like a doctor
this is what i'm trying to say to you
right for less than ten dollars per
person per meal
blue apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with proportion ingredients to
make
a delicious home-cooked meal choose from
a variety of new recipes each week like
the ones i told you or let blue rapings
killing every team surprise you the
recipes are not going to be repeated for
another year so you're never going to
get bored you customize your recipes
each week based on your preferences blue
apron has several delivery options so
you can choose what fits your needs and
there's no weekly commitment so you only
get deliveries when you want them each
meal comes with a step-by-step easy to
follow recipe card proportioned
ingredients and they can be prepared in
40 minutes or less you understand me you
go home you cook you take a shower bam
you're ready to go plus blue apron's
freshness guarantee promises that every
ingredient is gonna
deliver fresh and ready to cook or
they'll take care of you they gotta make
it right do me a favor check out this
week's menu and get your first three
meals for free you understand me with
free shipping by going to blueapron.com
joey you'll love how good it feels
you'll love how it tastes and you'll
love creating incredible meals and in no
time you'll be a chef you'll be
impressing your friends so do me a favor
go to blue apron.com
joey blue apron is a better way to cook
i told you savages when i go to jiu
jitsu when i have shorts on it's only me
undies why
because of the micro moldor they're
comfortable there's no ball sweat your
ass don't sweat everything's fresh and
you can't pay for that you understand me
that is peace of mind elevate your
underwear game to the next level with me
undies you perfected your wardrobe but
what about the stuff nobody gets to see
why are you wearing underwears with skid
marks and little yellow stains in the
front like a [ __ ] sandwich come on
yeah i got something that'll change your
life for the better
me undies what's the first thing you put
on and the last thing you take off at
night it's your underwear make your most
important piece of clothing
be the best it can be
what me undies listen they're soft they
feel good and they're delivered right to
your goddamn door me undies are designed
in los angeles and made from source
micro moldol a fabric three times softer
than cotton so me and these softened and
luxe undies come in ever changing
selection of classic colors
bold shades and adventurous patterns i
got camouflage i got flower ones i got
red ones with black dots my daughter
always tells me daddy why are you
wearing panties i tell them they're not
panties they're my your little savage
and guess what you can save time and
money each month with a monthly
subscription but if you're not ready for
that that's okay i'm going to save you
some bakala anyway that's because
meundies is offering you 20 off your
first pair just use the special url
meundies.com
joey and get 20 off your first pair so
go ahead
mother's day is coming you don't want to
go eat over there with nasty underwears
you deserve it go to meundies.com
joey again
meundies.com joey i want to thank blue
apron i want to thank me undies i want
to thank honor.com i want to thank my
main man
the one and only mickey [ __ ] gull and
while bill and dick syed for kicking in
tonight thanks uncle joey thanks for
having me always but most importantly i
want to thank you [ __ ] savages for
having her back and for being loyal you
know i love you [ __ ] with
everything i got
don't forget lovely live this weekend
and next week i'm at bakersfield i'm
gonna stop by matt baker's jiu jitsu
[ __ ] school and i'm gonna be at
the temblor brewing company i love you
guys stay black have a great weekend
don't forget uncle joey loves you thank
you guys again for being here whoa
so
foreign
[Music]
you